welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford school of medicine today we are
discussing caffeine caffeine is one of
the most widely used substances on the
planet
estimates are that more than 90 percent
of adults and as many as 50 percent of
kids that is adolescents and teenagers
use caffeine on a daily basis caffeine
is an amazing molecule most people are
familiar with caffeine's ability to
increase alertness and to reduce our
feelings of sleepiness and fatigue and
indeed it does that but what most people
are not aware of is that caffeine acts
as a strong reinforcer what I mean by
reinforcer is that when caffeine is
present in a drink or food and yes
indeed caffeine is present in many foods
even unbeknownst to us
when it's present in drinks and foods we
actively come to like those foods and
drinks more than if caffeine were not
contained in those foods and drinks so
it reinforces our liking of particular
foods and drinks and indeed it even
reinforces our liking of the containers
they are consumed from and the company
we keep when we consume foods and drinks
that contain caffeine that is caffeine
is not just a stimulant caffeine is a
reinforcer and it's a reinforcer that
plays an active role in almost
everybody's daily life we can say that
with confidence because as I mentioned a
moment ago more than 90 percent of
people are consuming caffeine and most
people think that they consume caffeine
because it makes them feel more alert
but there are many reasons why you're
consuming caffeine and I'm not going to
tell you that consuming caffeine is
necessarily bad in fact today I'm going
to tell you about many of the positive
health benefits of caffeine including
neuroprotective effects anti-depressive
effects and certainly perform enhancing
effects both for mental performance and
for physical performance now that said
there are certain situations in which
you want to avoid caffeine and there are
certain people who might opt to avoid
caffeine that's especially the case when
one thinks about caffeine not just as a
stimulant but as a reinforcer in fact
caffeine is such a strong reinforcer
that if even tiny amounts of caffeine
are present in certain foods and drinks
you will very quickly come to prefer
those foods and drinks over other
choices which can be a good thing or a
bad thing depending on what sorts of
food and drink choices you're trying to
make so today I'm going to inform you
about how caffeine works at a
mechanistic level I promise to do that
with a minimum of nomenclature and such
that even if you don't have a background
in biology you will be able to digest
that information easily and then I'll
tell you how to use caffeine to your
advantage or conversely how to avoid
caffeine at certain times to your
advantage so today's episode will focus
both on mechanisms and tools that is the
use and leverage of caffeine to improve
mental health physical legal health and
performance before we go any further
into today's discussion I want to tell
you about some recent results about a
molecule that's found in certain
caffeinated Beverages and that has been
proven to be very useful for both weight
loss mental performance and controlling
blood sugar levels and that's glp-1 or
glucagon-like peptide one glucagon like
peptide one is found in the brain and
body it acts both on the brain and body
it does many different things but one of
its primary effects that's been
discovered is to reduce hunger and it
does that two ways
it does that by activating certain
neurons in your hypothalamus so that's a
brain region that controls hunger and
satiety it makes us feel full at the
level of the brain so it makes us feel
sated that is and it actually makes us
feel full turns out that glp-1 acts on
certain receptors in the gut to make us
feel as if we've ingested enough food it
doesn't necessarily make us feel as if
our gut is distended but it makes us
feel full that's really interesting
because if you think about it when we
eat our stomach fills up obviously and
that information has to be communicated
to the brain such that the brain can
then send satiety signals that actually
shut off our hunger and believe it or
not the brain actually activates signals
to reduce the desire to chew when our
stomach is full and glp-1 as I mentioned
works on the brain to create these
feelings of satiety as if we've had
enough and to reduce our desire to eat
more and glp-1 acts directly on the gut
to give us a slight sense of fullness in
the gut which then is communicated to
the brain so really there are two
parallel signals being sent when we have
glp-1 present in our system now a little
bit of relevant history on glp1 it was
actually discovered in gila monsters
these are these
um reptiles that can go long periods of
time without eating and a very clever
scientists decide to study why it is
that certain animals like gila monsters
can go a long period of time without
ingesting anything and it's because they
produce very large amounts of glp-1 they
isolate the peptide from glp-1 then they
looked for the analogous peptide
in humans and it turns out that does
exist and as I mentioned it's released
in both brain and body to make you feel
full and sated why am I telling you all
this well today we're going to talk
about caffeine and there's one
particular caffeine source which is
yerba mate and there's some other forms
of teas similar to Yerba mate that
stimulate the release of glp-1
significantly
there are also nowadays drugs which are
called analogs of glp1 so these are
drugs that mimic or are identical to the
kind of glp one that you would make and
those drugs are proving to be very
effective for the treatment of certain
forms of diabetes and for the treatment
of obesity but they trigger enormous
amounts of glp-1 pathway Activation so
those are extreme cases for people that
are really struggling for weight loss
but the clinical trials and the data
that are out there in the general
population now are very very promising
for glp-1 analogues
yerba mate tea
provided it's not the smoked variety and
I mentioned that because a number of
people have cued me to the fact that
yerba mate teas come in smoked varieties
and non-smoke varieties and the smoked
varieties are thought to perhaps be
carcinogenic that is pro-cancer causing
so I advise people to avoid smoked
varieties of yerba mate tea but yerba
mate teas are known to stimulate
significant amounts of glp-1 release and
so they can be effective as a weight
loss tool mainly by blunting appetite
and again they do that both at the level
of the brain and at the level of the gut
now all of what I just told you has been
known for some period of time but there
are a new set of findings that were just
published in cell reports medicine cell
Press Journal excellent Journal which
indicate exactly how it is that glp-1
stimulates both satiety and can trigger
additional weight loss through other
mechanisms and I find the mechanism to
be really interesting and actually
really important given some other topics
we've covered on this podcast before so
the basic finding is that glp-1 whether
or not it's stimulated through the
release of uh analog drug that one is
prescribed or by drinking yerba mate tea
for instance and stimulate release of
your own so-called endogenous glp-1
yes it makes you feel more full at the
level of brain and body but it turns out
it also stimulates thermogenesis now
thermogenesis is the active utilization
of more metabolic energy and fat cells
in particular so-called beige and brown
fat cells are a potent source of
thermogenic activity in your body the
basic background is that you have white
adipose cells so white fat cells you
have beige fat cells and you have brown
fat cells and the beige and brown ones
are fat cells that you actually want
more of they are not abundant under your
skin they're abundant really around your
clavicles and your upper neck they are
the ones that generate Heat and the
beige and brownness of them is actually
the consequence of having a lot of
mitochondria in those cells when glp-1
is elevated in your system it turns out
that it communicates to those white fat
cells and helps convert them into beige
and brown fat cells that is it takes fat
cells that are not doing anything useful
for you except being stored energy and I
think most people out there would like
to have fewer of those white adipose
cells there are few of you out there
that actually need more of them that are
too thin too lean but most people are
suffering from having too many of these
white adipose cells well when you ingest
yerba mate tea or you were to take a
glp-1 analog or stimulate glp-1 in any
number of different ways yes you
stimulate increase satiety but you're
also stimulating the conversion of these
white fat cells into beige and brown fat
cells which makes you more thermogenic
and over time raises your basal
metabolic rate so you're burning more
calories even at rest it also makes you
feel as if you're more comfortable in
colder environments at rest this is very
much the same as the mechanism that
induced when you were to say take a cold
shower or do regular ice baths or get
into cold water regularly that too
stimulates the conversion of white fat
cells to beige and brown fat cells so I
like these findings very much because
they provide a mechanistic coherence
they provide that is a really nice story
as to how something like glp-1 could be
so effective for weight loss yes on the
one hand glp-1 is reducing appetite and
that of course will help people
maintain or lose weight but it's also
increasing basal metabolic rate and we
now know how that's accomplished it's
likely accomplished at least through
this one mechanism by the stimulation of
conversion of these white fat cells
which don't do much for us except at as
energy storage units to these
metabolically mitochondrial Rich beige
and brown fat cells which you can think
of as sort of the oil in the candle that
allows your furnace your metabolism to
burn at a higher temperature and a
higher rate so that's the mechanism and
the basic tool takeaway is that if you
are somebody who's interested in losing
weight and you want to leverage the
glp-1 pathway drinking a cup or two of
yerba mate tea early in the day would be
a great way to stimulate glp-1 release
there are other ways to stimulate GOP
One release you can get it through
certain forms of exercise in particular
fasted exercise this is actually a vote
in favor of fasted exercise there's a
debate as to whether or not fasted
cardio burns more fat than non-fasted
cardio and the data basically say no it
doesn't really matter but that doesn't
really take into account the longer Arc
of things like glp-1 release so that
needs to be taken into consideration so
you could do fasted cardio you could
drink yerba mate tea keeping in mind
that yerbomate tea does contain caffeine
we'll talk more about the specific forms
of stimulants including caffeine that
mate has but mate would be a great way
to stimulate glp-1 release and then of
course for those of you that are
interested in more robust activation of
glp-1
then perhaps you might want to consider
some of the new prescription glp-1
analogs that are out there but that's a
more severe stimulus for glp-1 of course
and for everybody regardless of whether
or not you're trying to lose weight gain
weight or maintain weight I think we're
going to be hearing a lot more about
glp1 analogs and drinks and supplements
and things of that sort that stimulate
glp-1 in the very near future because it
does appear to be a very important
biological mechanism before we begin I'd
like to emphasize that this podcast is
separate from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford it is however part of
my desire and effort to bring zero cost
to Consumer information about science
and science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is levels
levels is a program that lets you see
how different foods affect your health
by giving you real-time feedback on your
diet using a continuous glucose monitor
now blood glucose or blood sugar is a
critical aspect of your immediate and
long-term health and indeed your
feelings of vigor and mental Clarity and
well-being at any moment one one of the
key things is to know how different
foods and food combinations and timing
of food intake is impacting blood
glucose and with levels you're able to
assess all of that in real time
I tried levels and what it taught me for
instance was that I can eat certain
foods at certain times of day but if I
eat them at other times a day I get a
blood sugar crash it also taught me for
instance how to space my exercise and my
food intake turns out for me exercising
fasted is far more beneficial that's
something I learned using levels and
it's completely transformed not just the
spacing and timing of my diet and
exercise but also use of things like the
sauna and other activities it's been a
tremendous learning for me that's really
shaped an enormous number of factors in
my life that have led to me feeling far
more vigorous with far more mental focus
and physical strength and endurance so
if you're interested in learning more
about levels and trying a continuous
glucose monitor yourself go to
levels.link huberman again that's
levels.link l-i-n-k slash huberman
today's episode is also brought To Us by
eight sleep eight sleep makes Smart
mattress covers with cooling Heating and
sleep tracking capacity I've talked many
times on this podcast about the critical
relationship between sleep and body
temperature that is in order to fall
asleep and stay deeply asleep throughout
the night our body temperature needs to
drop by about one to three degrees and
conversely when we wake up in the
morning that is in large part because of
our body heating up by one to three
degrees now people have different core
body temperatures and they tend to run
colder or hotter throughout the night
eight sleep allows you to adjust the
temperature of your sleeping environment
so that you have the optimal temperature
that gets you the best night's sleep I
started sleeping on an eight-sleep
mattress cover about eight months ago
and it has completely transformed by
sleep I sleep so much deeper I wake up
far less during the middle of the night
if at all and I wake up feeling far
better than I ever have even after the
same amount of sleep if you want to try
eight sleep you can go to eightsleep.com
huberman to save up to four hundred
dollars off their sleep fit holiday
bundle which includes their new pod 3
cover eight sleep currently ships in the
USA Canada United Kingdom select
countries in the EU and Australia again
that's eightsleep.com
huberman today's episode is also brought
To Us by Roka Roku makes eyeglasses and
sunglasses that are the absolute highest
quality the company was founded by two
All-American swimmers from Stanford and
everything about Roca eyeglasses and
sunglasses were designed with
performance in mind I've spent a
lifetime working on the biology the
visual system and I can tell you that
your visual system has to contend with
an enormous number of challenges in
order for you to see clearly for
instance when you move from a sunny area
to a shady area and Back Again whether
or not you're looking at something up
close or often to the distance Roka
understands the biology of the visual
system and has designed their eyeglasses
and sunglasses accordingly so you always
see with perfect clarity Roca eyeglasses
and sunglasses were initially designed
for activities such as running and
cycling and indeed they are very
lightweight most of the time I can't
even remember that they're on my face
they're so lightweight but the important
thing to know about Roka eyeglasses and
sunglasses is that while they can be
used during sports activities they also
have a terrific aesthetic and they can
be used just as well for wearing to work
or out to dinner Etc if you'd like to
try Roca eyeglasses and sunglasses you
can go to Roka that's roka.com and enter
the code huberman to save 20 off on your
first order again that's Roca roka.com
and enter the code huberman at checkout
the huberman Lab podcast is now
partnered with momentous supplements to
find the supplements we discussed on the
huberman Lab podcast you can go to live
momentous spelled ous live momentous.com
huberman I should just mention that the
library of those supplements is
constantly expanding again that's
livmentis.com huberman let's talk about
caffeine
so as I mentioned earlier caffeine is
consumed by basically most all adults
every single day and consumed at very
regular times each day
in fact if you were to take a look at
your caffeine intake or the caffeine
intake of somebody close to you what you
would realize is that they don't do so
well if their caffeine intake arrives
even 10 20 or 30 minutes past their
expected or usual intake of caffeine
that's pretty remarkable and it brings
to mind ideas that we are all quote
unquote addicted to caffeine or that
caffeine is somehow bad I'm certainly
not going to make the argument that
caffeine is bad first of all I'm a
regular caffeine user I wouldn't call
myself a caffeine abuser but I am a
regular caffeine user and caffeine is
known to have certain health benefits I
listed off a few of them earlier but
I'll mention those again now before
going forward caffeine is known to have
certain neuroprotective effects and that
is because of its ability to increase
neuromodulators such as dopamine but
also other so-called catecholamines like
norepinephrine if you don't know what
those names mean these are molecules
that increase levels of alertness
motivation and drive and so then
therefore not surprisingly the
large-scale analyzes of the relationship
between depression and caffeine shows
that provided people are not drinking so
much caffeine that it makes them overly
anxious
that regular intake of caffeine is
inversely related to levels of
depression so it may have some
antidepressant effects and those could
be direct or indirect what do I mean by
that well you can imagine that if people
are ingesting caffeine and they are more
motivated to do work and pursue quality
social interactions then the probability
that they will have depression could be
lower
it could also be that there are Direct
effects on the chemical systems of the
brain that relate to mood and well-being
that could offset depression it is not
clear whether or not the effects of
caffeine in countering depression are
direct or indirect nonetheless there's a
relationship there and it's an
interesting and positive one
or I should say negative correlation
positive effect overall on mood and
well-being to be exact
now it's also the case that caffeine can
improve mental Performance and Physical
performance this has been demonstrated
in tens of thousands of studies I will
review a few studies on this in
particular today but to just give you a
sense of how caffeine works at the level
of its timing and impact on mental
Performance and Physical performance
when we ingest caffeine provided that we
don't have a lot of food in our stomach
and that our blood sugar isn't
particularly High generally we
experience an increase in alertness
within about five minutes and that
increase in focus and alertness Peaks
around 30 minutes after ingestion of
caffeine and persists for as long as 60
minutes now this is assuming that one
takes caffeine in pill form or drinks
the entire caffeine drink within a short
period of time but a little bit later
I'll talk about how you can consume
caffeine at regular intervals while
doing mental work or physical work in a
way that can further increase mental
Performance and Physical performance but
let's just touch on what caffeine intake
really does for mental Performance and
Physical performance
perhaps the most robust finding across
all of the studies that I've examined is
that caffeine reduces our reaction time
that is it improves our reaction time it
doesn't make it longer it makes it
shorter so for instance in a laboratory
study where people were asked to hit a
lever every time they hear a tone you
can greatly reduce the time between the
tone and the pressing of the lever if
people ingest caffeine about 30 minutes
before they do that task now that seems
like a trivial task but this is also
seen in the domain of sports performance
and even in cognitive performance where
people have to arrive at a particular
answer to a question and the answer to
that question has to be pulled from
their memory banks within their brain
their hippocampus for instance a brain
structure involved in memory and if you
are asking people for instance to
remember the capitals of different
states or cities or to remember certain
historical facts they will do that at a
particular rate but if they've ingested
caffeine within the hour prior here
their ability to recall that information
is much much better they are faster and
it does not appear that accuracy is
reduced in fact in many cases accuracy
is enhanced and that's because caffeine
both works on the reaction time systems
of the brain and body
I'll talk about the mechanisms for that
in a little bit but it also stimulates
certain neurotransmitters and so-called
neuromodulators within the brain and
body that give the neural circuits in
the brain that are associated with
learning and memory
a lower threshold to activation what
does that mean that means that we are
better able to access the brain
circuitry involved in learning and
memory when we have a certain amount of
caffeine circulating in our system so
this makes caffeine an incredible
performance enhancing compound and I
could give you tens of thousands of
examples of this in humans but before I
do that I want to just touch on what we
know about the existence of caffeine in
nature and what the existence of
caffeine in nature and its effects on
other animals tells us about what
caffeine does in humans because as I
alluded to earlier
what caffeine is doing for us is not
just making us more alert improving our
memory improving our reaction time and
so on it's actually acting as a powerful
reinforcer of experience and its acting
as not just a powerful reinforcer of the
caffeine containing drink that we drink
but also the mug that it's contained in
plus the person that we might be sitting
across from when we consume that
caffeine and so on and so forth if it's
a little bit hard for you to
conceptualize what a reinforcer is
and why I'm calling it a reinforcer
let me spell it out in three specific
ways
we often hear about the word reward and
we think okay if we do certain things
and we like the outcome then those
certain things are rewarded right if
we're doing something we receive praise
the praise is the reward and therefore
we are more likely to do that thing in
the future
in fact a lot of parenting is like that
and a lot of life is like that
however when we hear the word reward we
often think about something that feels
good to us and certainly if we've worked
hard and we get some praise that's
natural for the praise to feel good to
us or for instance if we we work very
hard and we get a certain outcome
a trophy a financial outcome a degree
outcome
recognition Etc all of those can act as
rewards but those are all conscious
rewards we are aware that they are
happening
reinforcers are a little bit different
because the word reinforcement can apply
to conscious rewards of the sort that I
just described but there are also many
ways in which caffeine stimulates the
release of chemicals in our body that
act as reinforcers but those reinforcers
are subconscious that is we are not
aware that they cause this preference
for the activities that cause their
release so the study I'm about to
describe
beautifully I believe
encapsulates how is it that humans came
to consume caffeine and why caffeine
exists in nature and the powerful
effects of caffeine as a reinforcing
agent both in animals insects and in you
and meat and the title of the paper is
caffeine and floral nectar enhances a
pollinator's memory of reward keep in
mind that caffeine is made from Plants
some of USA duh but I think some of us
don't realize that the reason why
there is caffeine in coffee is because
coffee comes from a plant it's a coffee
bean certain teas which of course are
plants that people Brew
caffeine is contained in those teas such
as yerba mate
well why would This Bitter substance
because in fact caffeine is quite bitter
in high concentrations why would This
Bitter substance be something that
insects or animals would want to consume
at all it turns out that in most plants
caffeine is present in small enough
quantities that insects and other
animals and in fact we can't actually
taste the caffeine if I were to give you
a little bit of pure caffeine yes it
would be a stimulant for you but you
would say that it tasted awful it's in a
category of compounds that would
strongly stimulate the bitter receptors
on your tongue and would make you cringe
and pucker and essentially walk away
from whatever it is that contain that
caffeine
and from the experience that contained
that caffeine well in nature caffeine is
present in very low concentrations or is
masked by other flavors Within
flowers beans and plants and what this
paper really points to is that caffeine
in nature is acting as a reinforcer for
bees that are consuming different nectar
so the way that it works is that bees of
course go from flower to flower
and they are consuming the nectar they
are bringing nectar and pollen back to
the hive and that provides critical
nourishment for
the bee Colony the bees are foraging in
a way that includes information about
color in particular ultraviolet color
things that we can't see but they can
see because they have different
photoreceptors than we do what this
study shows is that
plants and Nectars that contain very
small amounts of caffeine
are the preferred sources of food for
bees and the study is beautiful because
they were able to confirm that they
could mask the caffeine taste so if they
know that the bees are not preferring
the taste of caffeine
but what they do is they pair caffeine
with different food sources for the bees
then they remove the caffeine and what
they find is that the bees very strongly
prefer
flavors that contain caffeine not
because they could taste the caffeine
but rather for the way that those
caffeine-containing flavors made the
bees feel
so how do those caffeine-containing
flavors make the bees feel the same way
that they make you and I feel a little
bit more alert and thereby
able to do more work for the bee the
more work is the consumption of more
food which then has a further
reinforcing effect so what we're really
talking about here is the fact that a
caffeine exists in nature in Plants it
exists in concentrations that are very
low so low in fact that they are not
detectable to The Taste receptors of
insects and in many cases to The Taste
receptors of humans and of course there
can be high levels of caffeine in a
plant but if the plant also contains
compounds that mask the flavor of
caffeine well then those plants are
going to essentially be even stronger
reinforcers for the flavor of the plant
okay so now we're talking about strong
flavors plus strong neurostimulant
effects of caffeine
and the most important Point here is
that all of these effects of caffeine
are subconscious it is not because the b
or U likes the taste of caffeine in fact
most people when they take their first
sip of coffee they find that it tastes
bitter and kind of noxious they don't
like it you may not even remember that
because it happened so long ago and
because caffeine is such a strong
reinforcer that very quickly you come to
like the taste of coffee you might even
come to like the feeling of your mug in
your hand you might even come to like
the smell of coffee and so on and so
forth and that's because caffeine
stimulates the release of certain
neurochemicals in the brain in
particular dopamine and acetylcholine
two neuromodulators that increase our
focus and alertness and our feelings of
well-being a little bit later I'll tell
you that caffeine stimulates the release
of dopamine in a way that's very much
distinct from the classical dopamine
pathway associated with addiction and
reward in fact we can think of caffeine
as having a somewhat privileged access
to the reward systems
I'll give you a bit of a hint of where
this is going caffeine stimulates the
release of dopamine and acetylcholine
not within the classic so-called
mesolimbic reward pathway that's just
fancy nerd speak for the reward Pathways
of the brain they're associated with
things like sex and Food and Drugs of
abuse like cocaine and methamphetamine
but rather caffeine seems to stimulate
the release of dopamine in the parts of
the brain that are associated with
alertness and cognition meaning the
forebrain
this is very important we have multiple
dopamine systems in the brain and body
and caffeine seems to stimulate dopamine
directly within this components of the
brain that are associated with Clarity
of thought and well-being but more so
Clarity of thought now I'm also talking
about caffeine as a strong reinforcer in
that it makes you feel good overall
and it does and that suggests that it
also Taps into the more classic reward
pathway but it does that in a very
interesting and frankly almost
diabolical way when we regularly ingest
caffeine it stimulates the increase in
dopamine receptors at multiple sites
throughout the brain but in particular
within the reward Pathways of the brain
so not the areas of the brain they're
associated with focus and Clarity of
thought and cognition it does that but
it is also increasing the level of
dopamine receptors in the reward pathway
and what that means is that for any
dopamine that's released in response to
a positive experience social experience
or any number of the other things that
can stimulate dopamine release
there are more receptors more parking
spots if you will for that dopamine to
arrive at and to exert its
increases in mood increases in
motivation and overall feelings of drive
and excitement
so there are four ways that caffeine
works that we need to understand first
of all caffeine acts as a reinforcing
agent it increases the probability that
you will return to and engage in a
certain activity or consume a certain
beverage or food second of all caffeine
increases
dopamine and acetylcholine which are
both neuromodulators in the forebrain
which helps us improve our ability to
think
to modify our rule sets that is to
adjust our strategies for different
social situations and mental demands and
physical demands
and third it increases the number and
efficacy of dopamine receptors in the
reward Pathways of the brain that is it
makes things that would feel pretty good
feel even better and fourth caffeine
acts as an antagonist to adenosine which
offsets the sleepiness that we would
otherwise feel from the accumulation of
adenosine that occurs as we are awake
for more and more hours throughout the
day so let's talk first about caffeine
as a reinforcing agent again
this was first most beautifully
demonstrated in this study on honeybees
where the bees prefer Nectars that
contain caffeine
and that all makes perfect sense in
terms of the Ecology of bees and flowers
that contain nectar there's an advantage
at least in terms of adaptation that the
flower benefits because of distribution
of things from the flower which is good
for the flowers and the bees benefit
because they're getting food and so
there's a kind of a symbiosis there but
with humans we we're consuming caffeine
containing beverages for our sake I
don't think we have it in mind nor do
the bees have it in mind frankly that
we're trying to preserve the plants that
provide the caffeine I think we would
all
um suffer or I should say 90 of adults
would suffer greatly if all the
caffeine-containing coffee and tea
plants were gone certainly but most of
us are not consuming coffees and teas
and caffeine containing foods because
we're thinking about the plants they
come from and we want to help those
plants we're thinking about how we want
to help ourselves and yet the point of
the reinforcing effects of caffeine are
that they are largely subconscious we
are not aware of them now you might say
no that's not true when I drink caffeine
it makes me feel really good so I'm
aware it makes me feel good
in order to illustrate how reinforcement
really works
let me give you the counter example
which would be an aversive agent so we
have reinforcing agents and we have
aversive agents let's say that there
were compounds in nature that exist in
plants that are aversive and indeed they
are and let's say that these compounds
were present at such low concentrations
that you couldn't taste them
let's say you wake up in the morning and
you go to your refrigerator and you open
it up and you are thirsty and so you
reach for a nice um You Know Rich red
containing beverage in a glass jar maybe
it looks like cranberry juice or
something of that sort or even a nice
clear glass of water it looks like a jug
of water a glass of water and you drink
that
tastes fine to you maybe even tastes
great to you
and then let's say about 30 minutes
later you feel a little queasy you feel
a little off you feel like going back to
sleep you just don't feel very good
you don't know why but your nervous
system
is a predictive machine and it has a
process in which it back integrates
where I should say integrates backwards
into your immediate experience that
preceded that not so good feeling
we can reliably say that there is a much
lower probability that the next day when
you wake up that you would reach for
that same
beverage or for that same container even
and maybe if you're in a novel
environment maybe you're staying in an
Airbnb or a hotel or something of that
sort you might even find that you don't
really like the kitchen in which you
consume that beverage in the first place
now you don't know why
and unless you got very very sick the
day before it's unlikely that you would
have such a strong response that you
would entirely avoid for instance water
or glass jars containing liquids Etc
let's say you went back to the
refrigerator and you consumed beverage
again and you just didn't feel so well
you felt less good than you normally
would
well even without any ability to taste
what's in that beverage and even without
any understanding of what was happening
to you at a conscious level
there is a very very high probability
that you will avoid drinking that
particular beverage and certainly at
that location
and in the same volume
in the subsequent days that's just the
way that aversive agents work and they
work by way of activating neurons in the
gut that communicate with areas in the
brain that give us this feeling of
queasiness and for some of you hearing
this that pathway and that association
with times in which you felt queasy and
as if you wanted to vomit
is so powerful that you might even be
feeling some of that
symptomology now for certain people
that's going to be increased salivation
which precedes vomiting we know that
there's a class of neurons in the brain
related to an area called area post
trauma that actually stimulates vomiting
and if I keep talking about this I'll
probably feel like I want to vomit so
I'm going to move on from this in a
moment so when we ingest caffeine
containing Beverages and Foods it's the
exact opposite scenarios to what I just
described caffeine as a reinforcer makes
us feel slightly better or a lot better
in the immediate minutes and hours after
we ingest it
so it's acting as a reinforcing agent
not just while you're under the effects
of caffeine but for the things that
preceded the ingestion of caffeine which
is why you return again and again to
caffeine-containing beverages such as
coffee and tea or maybe even foods that
contain caffeine even if the taste of
those Foods is not something that you
would otherwise consider especially
delicious in fact most people when they
take their first sip of coffee or tea or
other caffeine containing beverage they
find to be very bitter and that's not
because of the taste of caffeine it's
because of the taste of the beverage
itself independent of caffeine however
when caffeine is present in there they
come to prefer that taste over most all
tastes in fact they will as I mentioned
earlier will invest a lot of financial
resources and time and energy to make
sure that they get that beverage what
they're trying to make sure is not that
they get that taste but that they get
the caffeine it is that positively
reinforcing and The Taste therefore
takes on new significance new meaning
and we come to associate it as positive
and in fact most of us including myself
love the taste of espresso love the
taste of coffee love the taste of yerba
mate
even if the initial taste the very first
time that we consume that beverage was
either neutral or negative and that is
all because of the reinforcing
properties of caffeine and then of
course there are the more direct actions
of caffeine that is the faster actions
of caffeine and just to list those off
again very briefly so that you have them
in mind going forward caffeine also
increases the release of dopamine and
acetylcholine both of which are
neuromodulators in the forebrain which
increases Clarity of thought and your
ability to rule switch your ability to
move from one context to another and
change and understand the Rules of
Engagement social engagement physical
engagement mental engagement and so
forth and as I mentioned before caffeine
also increases the number of dopamine
receptors in the reward pathway such
that any good thing that happens to you
any positive experience that you have
will have a more potent effect on your
feelings of well-being
and last but certainly not least
caffeine acts as an adenosine antagonist
it reduces your feelings of lethargy and
fatigue and your desire to sleep by
parking in The receptors for adenosine
and not allowing adenosine to have its
pro-sleepy if you will effects on your
brain and body I'd like to take a quick
break and acknowledge one of our
sponsors athletic greens athletic greens
now called ag-1 is a vitamin mineral
probiotic drink that covers all of your
foundational nutritional needs I've been
taking athletic green since 2012 so I'm
delighted that they're sponsoring the
podcast the reason I started taking
athletic greens and the reason I still
take athletic greens once are usually
twice a day is that it gets to be the
probiotics that I need for gut health
our gut is very important it's populated
by gut microbiota that communicate with
the brain the immune system and
basically all the biological systems of
our body to strongly impact our
immediate and long-term health
and those probiotics and athletic greens
are optimal and vital for microbiotic
health in addition athletic greens
contains a number of adaptogens vitamins
and minerals that make sure that all of
my foundational nutritional needs are
met and it tastes great if you'd like to
try athletic greens you can go to
athleticgreens.com huberman and they'll
give you five free travel packs that
make it really easy to mix up athletic
greens while you're on the road in the
car on the plane Etc and they'll give
you a year's supply of vitamin d3k2
again that's athleticgreens.com huberman
to get the five free travel packs and
the year supply of vitamin D3 K2 I'd
like to just briefly talk about
adenosine and some of its molecular
features and again if you don't have a
background in biology don't worry I
promise to make this very clear to
everyone
first of all caffeine is what's called a
methyl xanthine it's an it's a plant
alkaloid that's why caffeine itself is
very bitter again if I were to give you
just the tiniest little bit of pure
caffeine you would find it to be
extremely aversive and so these plants
that have snuck small enough amounts of
caffeine into them or that have masked
the flavor of caffeine with other
flavors such that bees and humans want
to consume them while we don't know what
plants think it does seem very
diabolical and very clever in that we
are seeking out these
caffeine-containing plants Beverages and
Foods
even though caffeine itself is this
alkaloid is very very bitter
methoxanthine that is caffeine
binds to adenosine receptors and they're
really two types of adenosine receptors
they're the so-called A1 receptors and
the A2 receptors and they're present in
different parts of the brain and body at
different levels
we don't have to get too far into
receptor subtypes more importantly to
understand is that adenosine makes us
feel tired because of the way that it
Taps into the ATP pathway
the ATP pathway is Central to energy
production and feelings of overall
energy in our brain and body in all
cells and organ systems
when caffeine binds to adenosine
receptors it it prevents adenosine from
breaking down certain components of the
energy production pathway and the net
consequence of that is increased cyclic
amp so basically
when we ingest caffeine we are biasing
our system towards the pro-energetic
aspects of these cellular Pathways now
it's really important to understand that
in biology
even if you block a receptor or you
prevent the activity of an enzyme and at
least in this case you end up with more
cyclic amp more energy
you're not really getting more energy
you're actually borrowing energy against
an overall system that is frankly
non-negotiable what do I mean by that
well let's say that you were to wake up
after six or eight hours of sleep and to
drink a lot of caffeine
and keep drinking caffeine throughout
the day throughout the day blocking
those adenosine receptors yes you'll
offset fatigue
you'll offset sleepiness because that
adenosine simply can't function but at
the point where the caffeine becomes
dislodged from the adenosine receptors
you will have a massive glut a backlog
of adenosine and you will feel extra
extra sleepy so really there's no way to
create more energy in your system really
what you're doing is you're changing the
timing in which the Sleepy signals and
the more energetic signals are arriving
and this is really important to
understand as as the backdrop to the
various tools that we're going to get
into next
in which you can use caffeine for
enhancing mental Performance and
Physical performance and other aspects
of Health but it's very important to
understand this concept that
when you wake up in the morning provided
that you slept well and enough the night
before your levels of adenosine will be
about as low as they will ever be
actually
in order to get your adenosine levels
really bottomed out you want to avoid
caffeine in the first 90 to 120 minutes
after waking we'll talk about why that
is because it turns out there's a way to
completely clear adenosine out of your
system in the hour or so after awaken
but for most people adenosine levels are
going to be close to their lowest after
a good night's sleep
but there's really no negotiating the
accumulation of adenosine that's going
to occur and going to bias you towards
feeling more sleepy than you would
otherwise that's going to occur
throughout the day there's really no way
to eliminate adenosine all you can
really do is block its function so it's
sort of like borrowing energy against
the fatigue that you will inevitably
feel now this actually has a very
important socioeconomical relevance
before caffeine was regularly consumed
by human beings we were really slaves to
the light dark cycle and this was
especially true before the presence of
artificial lighting but even before the
Advent of artificial lighting humans
were largely constrained to the outside
light dark cycle we need to be active
during the day and working during the
day and we need to be asleep at night
caffeine allows us to divorce ourselves
from that circadian cycle circadian just
means about 24 hours
caffeine allows us to do that at least
somewhat by way of increasing our
alertness that is spiking our alertness
at various times throughout the day and
even at night this is how we can have
shift workers for instance that can
sleep during the day and then drink a
strong cup of coffee at 8 pm and then
work into the night that ability
completely transformed our society now
of course the healthiest schedule we
know this with certainty the healthiest
schedule for brain and body is going to
be to be alert during the daytime and a
sleep at night there's no question about
that shift workers run into all sorts of
health problems and thank you shift
workers for doing the important work
that you do we need you air traffic
controllers paramedics firefighters
police officers Etc but we know that
there are serious health consequences
negative Health consequences that is for
shift workers but for most people out
there about 95 percent of people follow
a typical schedule where they're awake
during the day and asleep at night and
yet it used to be before the Advent of
caffeine containing beverages that if
you were sleeping in the afternoon you
either had to take an nap or battle that
sleepiness that your activity rhythms
and your sleep rhythms were governed by
these circadian changes in
availability of sunlight and when you
slept and you just didn't have the
ability to ingest a beverage that would
increase your levels of alertness
because you block adenosine so this is
important to understand that nowadays we
certainly live in a time in which we use
in fact 90 or more of adults and half or
more of adolescents and teenagers use
caffeine as a way to negotiate with to
borrow against this natural pattern of
adenosine making us sleepy but again
you're just offsetting the effects of
sleepiness that adenosine causes you
can't eliminate the adenosine entirely
the important point is that adenosine as
a pro-sleeping molecule is a
non-negotiable aspect of your biology in
fact it's so non-negotiable that every
24 hours you are going to release
adenosine and you're going to release
adenosine in direct proportion to how
long you've been awake so the longer
you've been awake the more adenosine
circulating your system they're really
only a handful of ways to completely
clear out adenosine the major one being
to get sleep
the other is to take a short nap which
of course is sleep but it's shallow
sleep or non-sleep deep breath so-called
nsdr has been shown to reduce levels of
adenosine
and
there are certain things such as viewing
morning sunlight which because of its
effects on cortisol can quote unquote
clear out adenosine we'll talk about
this in more detail in a few minutes and
there's also evidence that certain forms
of exercise provided that it's brief and
intense can also reduce adenosine not
just block its effects now that we've
talked about some of the incredible
mechanisms by which caffeine changes our
experience of Life increases alertness
and mood Etc I want to talk about the
use of caffeine as a tool now caffeine
is a very potent and useful tool for
enhancing mental health physical health
and performance but there are certain
considerations one has to keep in mind
in particular dose
now first off not everybody will respond
to the same dose of caffeine the same
way but we can reliably say that your
body weight is a good measure by which
you can estimate what a healthy useful
dose of caffeine would be so for most
people ingesting one to three milligrams
of caffeine per kilogram of body weight
is going to be the range in which
caffeine can have positive effects
without making us feel overly anxious
and give us that feeling that you know
we're jumping out of our skin and turn
the otherwise positive experience of
caffeine into an aversive one
for those of you that aren't familiar
with thinking in terms of kilograms and
normally think in pounds I'll just
quickly give you some general
estimations that for instance 100
kilograms equals 220 pounds so for me I
weigh 100 kilograms that means that
one to three milligrams again milligrams
thousandths of a gram one to three
milligrams of caffeine per kilogram of
body weight would mean for me I could
safely ingest 100 to 300 milligrams of
caffeine in a single dose in a single
drink
if that's the way I'm consuming it or
pill form if that's the way that I'm
consuming it and it's very likely that
that will be a tolerable dose however if
you are not somebody that's accustomed
to drinking caffeine on a regular basis
I suggest you start on the lower end of
that one to three milligrams per
kilogram of body weight range so for
instance if you're somebody who weighs
50 kilograms that's approximately 110
pounds and you would be pretty
comfortable ingesting somewhere between
50 and 150 milligrams of caffeine so
what I recommend is that people who are
considering using caffeine as a tool or
who are already ingesting caffeine start
to think about the dosage of caffeine
that you are ingesting or plan to ingest
and the timing in which you ingest that
caffeine relative to certain tasks
throughout your day you're waking and
you're sleeping we'll talk about that in
just a moment but the first step for you
is to figure out how much you weigh in
kilograms and then to go to that number
of one to three milligrams of caffeine
per kilogram of body weight and that's a
good range in which you might want to
explore the use of caffeine in a single
application meaning in a single dose now
I do realize that some people out there
are drinking coffee all day long or
having coffee in the morning and again
in the afternoon
what I'm referring to here
is the ingestion of caffeine in a single
bout right one cup of coffee or two cups
of coffee for instance to achieve that
100 to 300 milligram range if that's
what's appropriate for your body weight
but to avoid any confusion when I talk
about dosage of caffeine what I'm really
talking about is not the total amount of
caffeine ingested per day I'm talking
about the total amount of caffeine
ingested in one sitting or setting that
is and if you're somebody who's drinking
caffeine multiple times throughout the
day you can imagine for instance let's
say the
appropriate dose for you in order to get
an enhancement in mental performance or
physical performance is 200 milligrams
and you are somebody who's doing some
work in the morning and you want to have
that lift in the morning to be able to
focus better and you're doing some
physical exercise in the afternoon or
vice versa that you would ingest 200
milligrams of caffeine at two separate
times per day separated by about four
hours now you don't have to separate
them you could you could put them two
hours apart for instance but we'll talk
about half-life of caffeine and so forth
just keep in mind that if you're
ingesting 200 milligrams of caffeine and
that's the appropriate dose for you
based on your body weight and then you
are ingesting another 200 milligrams of
caffeine an hour later you're
effectively ingesting approximately 400
milligrams of caffeine which is going to
start exceeding the dose in which you
can normally tolerate without feeling
anxious and jittery with all of that
said there is a range of tolerance for
caffeine that's based on two things one
is a pre-existing disposition that is
whether or not your genetics and nervous
system and the backdrop of your life how
much stress you're experiencing tends to
make you feel more anxious and alert and
jittery before you ingest any caffeine
and the other is how so-called caffeine
adapted you are we often hear about
tolerance tolerance means something very
specific it's the ability to ingest more
and more of something
with a plateau that is a non no increase
or an actual reduction in the
effectiveness of that thing but here
we're not really talking about tolerance
to caffeine what we're talking about is
being caffeine adapted a simple way to
understand whether or not you're
caffeine adapted or not is that if you
drink caffeine and it tends to increase
your heart rate and make you feel more
alert and a bit more anxious then
chances are you are not caffeine adapted
provided the amount of caffeine is
within the healthy range for you that is
the ranges we talked about a moment ago
however you're somebody who drinks
caffeine and you actually feel alert and
relaxed chances are you are caffeine
adapted and so at various times during
today's episode I'll talk about people
who are caffeine adapted and people who
are not caffeine adapted we'll talk
about the use of caffeine every other
day I know a few habitual caffeine
drinkers including myself just the
simple mention of that probably sounds
aversive
um but there is actually great utility
to using caffeine every other day as
opposed to every day but just keep in
mind that some people will drink
caffeine and not not get much of a lift
from it at all other people will drink
caffeine and they will feel extremely
anxious even at dosages far lower than
that one to three milligrams per
kilogram of body weight range that I
described a moment ago so you have to
take into account individual differences
that said one to three milligrams of
caffeine per kilogram of body weight
for a given sitting you know for your
morning coffee or your or your morning
yerba mate tea is a good range from
which to start and I do encourage you to
go online and look up the various
Beverages and foods that you might be
eating that contain caffeine for
instance some people
are surprised to discover that the
coffee that they get from some of the
more standard popular vendors out there
the small coffee or the median coffee
for instance can contain as much as 400
to 600 milligrams of caffeine and the
large coffee that is often sold at those
commercial vendors can contain as much
as one gram 1 000 milligrams of caffeine
now you may be adapted to that such that
it doesn't make you feel anxious but if
you wonder why you feel irritable and
you get a headache when you don't get
that caffeine or that amount of caffeine
at precisely the time that you're used
to getting it each day that's because
you are consuming quite large
quantities of caffeine on a regular
basis so I do recommend whether or not
you drink soda or coffee or tea that you
figure out the source of that okay so
figure out what vendor you purchase it
from what kind of coffee and go online
and spend a little bit of time because
the information is out there to discover
what levels of caffeine you're actually
ingesting now if you happen to be
ingesting more than one to three
milligrams per kilogram of body weight
of caffeine that's not necessarily bad
however
you do want to be careful about
ingesting very high levels of caffeine
over long periods of time
in your life because there can be issues
that start to arise in particular a bias
towards higher levels of anxiety and
depletion of certain electrolytes
because caffeine is a diuretic can cause
you to lose sodium and other and other
things of that sort and also just from
Simply a dependent standpoint
it does appear that if you ingest high
levels of caffeine that is exceeding the
dosages that normally you could get away
with and get just as much mental
enhancing and physical enhancing
benefits
that you can cause some disruption to
the microvasculature you can bias
yourself towards headaches anxiety
attacks and it you can become actually
quite irritable when you're not getting
those higher levels of caffeine so I do
encourage you to figure out not just
what an appropriate caffeine dosage
would be for you but also how much
caffeine you might already be ingesting
the first tool I'd like to talk about is
one that I've mentioned before on this
podcast several times
and it's something that if you haven't
heard of will be very useful to you and
if you have heard this tool before I'm
going to add some additional features to
the description of this tool that should
make this worthwhile for you as well and
that is to delay your caffeine intake to
90 to 120 minutes after waking up on
most days and I'll be very clear as to
days in which you might want to ingest
caffeine
more closely to when you wake up why
would you want to delay your caffeine
intake
to 90 to 120 minutes after waking the
answer to that is very simple many
people wake up in the morning
they drink caffeine Within 10 20 30
sometimes within two minutes of waking
and they feel more alert naturally that
makes sense because of the effects of
caffeine in blocking the effects of
adenosine that I talked about earlier
and its effects on other
neurotransmitter systems but then what
they find is that in the early afternoon
in particular after lunch they
experience a dramatic dip in their
overall levels of energy the so-called
afternoon crash
and in most cases the way they respond
to that is to ingest more caffeine which
indeed can increase their levels of mood
and alertness
however as we'll soon talk about there
is a problem with ingesting caffeine in
the afternoon if it falls Within
8 or 10 or dare I even say 12 hours of
going to sleep and that is the caffeine
ingested in the afternoon
for most everybody I would say for 95
plus percent of people disrupts the
architecture and quality of their
nighttime sleep and I should say that it
doesn't necessarily impact their ability
to fall asleep and maybe even sleep
through the night but that the depth and
quality of that sleep is disrupted by
consuming caffeine in the afternoon a
little bit later I'll talk about how you
can offset some of those negative
effects if you absolutely require
caffeine in the afternoon but there's a
huge advantage to restricting your
caffeine intake to the early part of
your day but not consuming caffeine
within the first 90 to 120 minutes after
awaken
in fact many people find that if they
delay their caffeine intake to 90 to 120
minutes after waking up that they feel
more alert in the morning and they
completely avoid that afternoon crash
now that said many people including
myself do need a short nap or non-sleep
deep rest or other form of relaxation
for 10 to 30 minutes in the afternoon
that is natural and healthy I'm not
referring to the need for that when I
refer to the so-called afternoon crash
what I'm talking about in the afternoon
crash is a inability to recover energy
and focus and a need to consume more
caffeine just to make it through the
afternoon
by delaying caffeine intake from to 90
to 120 minutes after waking there are a
couple of things that are accomplished
first of all you offset that afternoon
crash and this is an effect that many
people experience the very first time
they start delaying their caffeine
intake to 90 to 120 minutes after waking
and the reason this works so well is the
following as I mentioned earlier
adenosine is a molecule that builds up
the longer that we are awake it is a
molecule that is reduced
or cleared from our system by sleep so
when we emerge from sleep regardless of
how long we've slept our adenosine
levels are lower than they were when we
went to sleep the previous night
if you slept
well enough and long enough those
adenosine levels can be very very low
but
they are never completely zero when you
wake up in the morning even if you're
one of these people that Springs out of
bed and is ready to attack the day and
here I'm certainly not describing myself
I'm not not one of those people I tend
to wake fairly slowly but if you're one
of those spring up and attack the day or
you're one of the people who moves more
slowly into your day
regardless there's still some residual
adenosine in your system and this is
particularly the case if you did not get
enough sleep or enough depth of sleep
the night before the the correct ratios
of slow wave sleep and rapid eye
movement sleep and for those of you
interested in optimizing sleep I'll just
refer you to our master your sleep
episode of The huberman Lab podcast the
perfect your sleep episode The huberman
Lab podcast and we have a tool kit for
sleep all of which are available zero
cost time stamped Etc at hubermanlab.com
you wake up in the morning and your
adenosine levels are low but they're not
zero and if you didn't sleep that well
or deeply enough the night before
you're going to have more adenosine in
your system
you might think the logical thing to do
is therefore to drink caffeine and to
block the adenosine that's there but
what happens if you do that is there's
an accumulation a sort of glut of
adenosine that hangs around
and then in the afternoon when the
effects of that caffeine start to wear
off you will experience the so-called
afternoon crash
as I mentioned earlier there is a way to
clear out the adenosine that's present
when you wake up in the morning
and to clear it out
essentially completely without just
blocking its receptors and letting it
accumulate or hang around and the way to
do that is to deliberately spike your
cortisol now many of you have heard of
cortisol the so-called stress hormone as
a bad thing and indeed chronically
elevated cortisol is a bad thing it
depletes your immune system it's bad for
psychosocial effects it tends to make us
feel anxious and on and on but cortisol
itself is not bad cortisol is wonderful
cortisol enhances the
efficiency of the immune system it makes
us alert and focused it stimulates our
metabolism it does a huge number of
positive things provided that it is
released
in a circadian fashion that is at the
appropriate times every 24 hours and
that it tends to Peak very close to
waking in fact one of the reasons you
wake up in the morning assuming that you
weren't woken up by some noise or or
sleeping in an environment that's too
warm Etc is that your cortisol levels
start to rise and shortly after waking
your cortisol levels will start to reach
their Peak and when I refer to a
cortisol pulse that's just I mean
biology nerd speak for a rise and peak
in cortisol you want that cortisol pulse
to occur early in the day close to
waking and you want that for a couple of
reasons first of all if you don't
restrict that cortisol pulse too early
in the day it will tend to bleed into
the later parts of the day and actually
a late shifted cortisol Peak is one of
the Hallmark signatures of depression
low level depression and serious
depression and it can start to disrupt
sleep and certainly can disrupt mood
metabolism and your immune system
so you want that cortisol Peak early in
the day how do you ensure that that
happens well you wake up in the morning
and whether or not you're a bounce out
of bed type or you're a more groggy you
kind of Wade slowly into the day type
like I am
you
wake up and you don't ingest caffeine
fine and in fact beneficial to hydrate
with water and electrolytes
terrific in fact I would say
necessary to get bright light in your
eyes ideally from sunlight I've talked
about this many many times before on the
podcast if you wake up before the sun
comes out then turn on bright artificial
lights but then certainly once the sun
is out and even on cloudy days in fact
in especially on cloudy days get outside
for anywhere from 5 to 20 maybe even 30
minutes do some work outside take your
breakfast outside if you're a breakfast
eater
get something done outside even if it's
just to get outside and get bright light
in your eyes why well because it's been
shown in studies on humans that getting
bright light in your eyes in the first
hour after waking or as soon as possible
after waking
increases the peak of that cortisol
pulse by 50 percent 5-0 and that
cortisol pulse yes increases mood yes
increases alertness but it does one
other very important thing which is that
that through an indirect pathway it can
clear out any residual adenosine that
might be present in your system when you
wake up in the morning
again this is going to be especially
important for those of you that are not
getting as much sleep or as much quality
sleep as you would like
it's going to be very important for you
to get that morning bright light ideally
from sunlight get that cortisol Peak
going other ways to increase that
cortisol Peak would be to do some
physical activity if you don't have time
to do a full workout well then getting
some movement you know 10 minutes of
skipping rope or even five minutes of
skipping rope or jumping jacks or
walking if that's all you have time for
ideally while getting the sunlight in
your eyes but that's going to zero out
the adenosine present in your system
if however you were to wake up and
immediately drink caffeine
caffeine itself can stimulate the
release of cortisol a little bit more
than it would otherwise be present in
your system but by blocking those
adenosine receptors
and because of the indirect effects of
caffeine on the cortisol system you
actually are reducing the clearance of
adenosine that would otherwise occur so
I realize that's a mouthful just to be
very clear if you wake up and you ingest
caffeine right away you're blocking the
adenosine receptor but you're not
clearing it out you're also preventing
cortisol from having its normal increase
in Rise such that it can directly clear
out adenosine because cortisol can clear
out adenosine and that's what you want
you want to be at maximum alertness and
focus in your morning and throughout
your day and by delaying your caffeine
to 90 to 120 minutes after waking you
set up your system so that you get that
morning cortisol Peak ideally a peak
that's even greater because you're
getting your
bright light viewing and then when you
ingest your caffeine 90 to 120 minutes
after waking not only will you be
craving it just a little bit but you
will be drinking that caffeine on an
already existing backdrop of increased
alertness for two reasons one is
adenosine is zeroed out
and your cortisol Peak is higher and so
now when you ingest caffeine you can
actually ingest levels of caffeine that
are a little more reasonable that almost
with certainty are going to fall in this
one to three milligrams per kilogram
dosage and will allow you to feel really
alert and will carry that alertness well
into the afternoon hours without the
need to drink more caffeine and thereby
will prevent you from drinking caffeine
and disrupting your nighttime sleep and
of course by getting better nighttime
sleep you're going to zero out your
adenosine even more so what I'm
describing here are essentially two
tools I'm telling you to get morning
sunlight and maybe some exercise in
conjunction with that even if it's brief
exercise
but the main tool of delaying caffeine
90 to 120 Minutes
after waking has immediate effects but
it also sets in motion a Cascade or
Domino Falls that lead to better sleep
and more wakefulness the next night and
the next day and so on and so forth now
I realize there are some people who just
simply cannot or will not delay their
caffeine 90 to 120 minutes after waking
for whatever reason
first off let me say that if you are
somebody who likes to wake up and do
very intense exercise within the first
90 minutes after waking
well in that case it would be
appropriate to ingest your caffeine just
prior to doing that exercise not a
problem not a problem but you should
expect that the combination of drinking
caffeine very shortly after waking plus
exercising very intensely shortly after
waking will increase the intensity of
that early afternoon and afternoon
fatigue that you feel now for some
people that's a great thing they can
afford to take a nap or do non-sleep
depressed
step away from work and so forth
in that case I strongly encourage you to
do whatever it is that allows you to get
regular exercise because regular
exercise is going to be very beneficial
in fact we did an entire episode called
toolkit for Fitness that describes a
couple of different but really one main
structure that allows you to get the
appropriate amount of resistance
training and cardiovascular training and
flexibility training throughout the week
I happen to follow that program and it
works very well and it does involve some
of those workouts to come very early in
the morning shortly after awaken and in
those cases I do ingest caffeine just
prior to those So within you know 10 20
minutes of waking however on other days
I personally delay my caffeine intake 90
to 120 minutes and I've done that to
great benefit and most people if not all
people that try that have reported the
same I should mention that some people
will find getting out to that 90 minutes
to be excruciatingly difficult because
they're so accustomed to ingesting
caffeine close to waking up in that case
maybe just push out your caffeine intake
by about 15 minutes each day until you
hit that 90 to 120 minute Mark and that
will make it much easier it might take
you a week or so to get there but once
you get there you'll find it to be quite
easy to maintain the other thing is that
if you are somebody who insists on
drinking caffeine very shortly after
waking I would encourage you to drink
half of your caffeine then and then the
other half of your caffeine about an
hour later that also will help offset
some of the afternoon crash for reasons
related to the so-called kinetics of
caffeine caffeine has a quarter life of
about 12 hours that means if you were to
ingest a cup of coffee
at let's say 8 A.M and let's say 100
milligram coffee just for sake of
Simplicity that about 25 percent of of
that caffeine action we wouldn't really
say 25 milligrams but about 25 of that
caffeine action will still be present at
8 pm that night which is pretty
remarkable so there's a long Arc of
caffeine effects and this is why it can
impede sleep if it's uh if we take
caffeine in the afternoon but again if
you're somebody who wakes up and you
really need caffeine right away and you
refuse to do this 90 to 120 minute delay
thing that I'm talking about well then
in that case I would drink half of your
caffeine upon waking and then a little
bit more or the other half
um about an hour later and that will
extend the Arc of that caffeine effects
such that you don't need it again in the
afternoon because you won't experience
the afternoon crash because of the way
caffeine works I should mention that if
you ingest caffeine on an empty stomach
it will have a more potent stimulant
effect
that will also tend to increase the
level of jitteriness that caffeine can
produce later I'll talk about ways to
offset that jitteriness but I'll just
tell you one tool now many people opt to
take 100 milligrams of theanine
t-h-e-a-n-i-n-e theanine
as a way to offset some of that
jitteriness
theanine will reduce the jitteriness of
caffeine which is why many energy drink
manufacturers and even some coffee
manufacturers are now putting theanine
in energy drinks and in ground coffee
because
no surprise it allows people to consume
more of that beverage and thereby
purchase more of that beverage which is
what these vendors want without feeling
overly anxious and jittery so you can
take pill form theanine if you want with
your caffeine I don't tend to do that
rather I control the total dosage of my
caffeine I do tend to consume caffeine
on an empty stomach because I do
restrict my caffeine intake to the early
part of the day and I generally eat my
first meal somewhere around 11AM and
then I generally eat my last meal
sometime around 8 PM or so those are
those are averages I would say plus or
minus an hour and that's not because I'm
religiously following any kind of time
restricted feeding it's just though
that's tends to work best with my
schedule and my appetite but again
that's a general theme there are days in
which I wake up and I'm very hungry and
I might ingest something
um a small snack or something or if I'm
meeting somebody for breakfast sometimes
I'll have breakfast sometimes I won't
and so on and so forth the point is that
you can get away with drinking less
caffeine to get the stimulant effect if
you do it on an empty stomach and if
you're somebody who likes to exercise on
an empty stomach
and I'm one of those people well then
ingesting caffeine just prior to
exercise can be a fantastic tool a
little bit later we'll talk about some
of the physical
performance enhancing effects of
caffeine but I'll just briefly jump to a
point about that as we relate to morning
exercise if you are somebody who
regularly ingests caffeine and we can
Define regularly by if you've ingested
caffeine every day for the last two
weeks your regular consumer of caffeine
whereas if you're somebody who only
ingests caffeine somewhere between two
and four times per week well then you
are not a regular consumer of caffeine
you're an intermittent user of caffeine
well if you're somebody who's a regular
user of caffeine the performance
enhancing effects of caffeine are going
to be most dramatic if you take two or
three days off from drinking caffeine
which to my mind as a I don't want to
call myself a caffeine addict but a
regular caffeine user that's a horrible
notion to me and this aversive notion
um because I do like the effects of
caffeine so much but if you really want
to see the maximum performance enhancing
effects of caffeine you will do either
one of two things you will either
abstain from caffeine for a few days or
three days prior to ingesting caffeine
or you will use caffeine on an empty
stomach it's very clear that caffeine on
an empty stomach enhances both the
mental and physical enhancing effects of
caffeine and of course all of that has
to be stated on the backdrop of
consideration that if you uh you know
you're very very hungry it can be make
it hard to concentrate and so on and so
forth so I'm not encouraging people to
starve themselves by any means uh
certainly don't do that but if you want
to maximize the performance enhancing
effects of caffeine you will consume it
on an empty stomach and then as a final
point to that caffeine is a diuretic it
causes to lose fluid and along with that
fluid to excrete sodium because of the
effects of caffeine on various processes
within the kidney so one thing that
works very well to maintain mood and
alertness
longer given a certain amount of
caffeine intake and to avoid the
jitteriness and and what can sometimes
feel like a crash or low blood sugar
feeling or even blurry vision is to make
sure that you consume at least an equal
volume of water with your caffeine and
ideally that water would contain maybe a
small pinch of salt or some sort of
electrolyte drink or powder rather for
me I use element full disclosure they
are a podcast affiliate and sponsor but
you don't need to do that you could
simply just have a glass of water
alongside your your coffee or espresso
or your bromate and just put a small
pinch of sea salt
in that or even just plain table salt
and that will help offset some of the
jitteriness of caffeine a lot of people
think that when they ingest caffeine
they get the jitteriness and crash
because their blood sugar is low and
while that can be the case oftentimes
it's simply because of the excretion of
sodium that's occurred when they've
ingested caffeine so I encourage you to
hydrate well and to hydrate with
something that contains a little bit of
sodium obviously not so much that
increases hypertension or something of
that sort of a small amount of sodium or
an electrolyte drink like element and
there are other electrolyte drinks out
there that can accomplish the same of
course just a couple of quick notes
about theanine because there are a
growing number of products out there
that contain theanine and they're
certainly a growing number of people out
there who are using theanine for the
effect that I described before which is
to offset some of the jitteriness
associated with caffeine containing
beverages or foods and of course I
should mention that I've talked about
the effects of theanine on sleep at that
sleep toolkit that you can find as a
free download you don't even have to
sign up for anything you just download
it from hubermanlab.com go to the menu
go to newsletter you'll see the toolkit
for sleep you'll see that the so-called
sleep stack that I use and recommend
includes magnesium three and eight
something called apogenin and theanine
although that sleep stack is designed to
be taken 30 to 60 minutes prior to sleep
and I make the point there and I'll make
it again here that ingesting theanine
prior to sleep is not a good idea if
you're somebody who tends to have very
vivid dreams night terrors or night walk
sleepwalking excuse me
Etc in that case eliminate theanine from
from the Sleep stack however a number of
people are using theanine and products
are using theanine to offset jitteriness
from caffeine-containing products during
the daytime daytime consumption that is
a couple of notes about theanine
theanine is something that is present in
green tea right it's now been created as
a supplement it's what's called a
non-protein amino acid so while there
are amino acids and proteins they're of
course amino acids and non-proteins and
theanine is one such non-protein amino
acid
theanine tends to stimulate the
so-called glutamate and glutamine
pathway it's actually very similar to
glutamate and glutamine
and it has a lot of effects on a lot of
different aspects of the nervous system
but the general effect of theanine is to
compete for The receptors for certain
neurotransmitters and the
neurotransmitters I'm referring to are
all excitatory neurotransmers things
like glutamate and they govern a
tremendous amount of our daily thinking
and action and feeling Etc because
they're present at so many connections
between neurons in the brain
theanine competes for The receptors for
glutamate
and tends to reduce our overall levels
of alertness so really when people take
theanine along with caffeine what
they're doing is they're really taking a
slight I don't want to call it
depressant to the point where it
misleads people and makes people think
that it will make you depressed the word
is a little bit misleading but tends to
reduce or blunt some of the more
excitatory pro-alertness actions of
neurons in the brain so when you take it
alongside caffeine tends to quote
unquote even things out a bit I should
mention that the dosages of theanine
that are effective for offsetting the
jitteriness of caffeine is 200 to 400
milligrams and the studies that I was
able to find
showed that essentially up to 900
milligrams per day can be safe but
that's a very high dosage of theanine in
fact so much so that it might increase
sleepiness to the point where it
wouldn't feel good there are also some
positive effects of daytime consumption
of theanine that are independent of
reducing the jitteriness of caffeine
for instance there's a study
demonstrating that 17 days of ingesting
theanine at least 200 to 400 milligram
dosage of at one to three times per day
can reduce depression and anxiety there
are also some good data out there
showing that theanine can have positive
effects on endothelial cells so blood
vessels capillaries and so on and
increase some of the functional blood
vessels allowing them to pass more blood
through them and give them a little bit
more elasticity if you will so theanine
has certain Pro sleep effects if it's
taken prior to sleep it can enhance the
quality depth and duration of sleep
again if you're a sleepwalker or
somebody who has extremely vivid dreams
from which you wake up in the middle of
the night probably best to leave out
theanine or maybe reduce the dosage down
to 100 milligrams and if that's still
too much then eliminate it completely
but theanine can be terrific for
enhancing quality depth and duration of
sleep it can also reduce the jitteriness
associated with caffeine containing
Beverages and foods and it has certain
antidepressant and pro-endothelial
effects that is it can offset
depression it can offset anxiety
although those are minor effects okay
subtle effects and it has been shown to
improve endothelial cell that is vessel
and capillary function and structure
in ways that can be beneficial for both
brain and body now one final point about
theanine that's worth paying attention
to is that the kinetics of theanine are
such that you don't need to take
theanine every time you ingest a
caffeinated beverage
when we ingest caffeine the peak effects
of caffeine occur about 30 minutes after
we drink it and there I'm assuming one
takes it all at once and this is a key
point that we'll come back to later
right rather than sipping your coffee
slowly over a couple of hours
or an hour if you drink all 200 or 300
milligrams of caffeine in your coffee
or 600 milligrams of your coffee if
you're getting one of those commercial
coffees
and you take theanine along with it
theanine will block some of the
jitteriness and anxiety-inducing effects
of caffeine that can occur
for much longer than the effects that
caffeine lasts so the peak and theanine
occurs about an hour after ingestion
I suppose if you want to get really
fancy and really dial in the kinetics
you could ingest theanine about half
hour before you ingest your caffeine but
I think that's getting a little bit
excessive in terms of controlling your
micro environment if you will I think it
would be perfectly fine too
take a hundred to two hundred milligram
capsule of theanine along with your
coffee or tea and so forth and just
realize that if you drink more caffeine
or you extend your caffeine intake over
several hours that you don't necessarily
have to take theanine repeated times
throughout the day I'd like to take a
brief break and thank our sponsor inside
tracker inside tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA to help you
better understand your body and help you
reach your health goals I've long been a
believer in getting regular blood work
done for the simple reason that many of
the factors that impact your immediate
and long-term Health can only be
analyzed from a quality blood test the
problem with a lot of blood and DNA
tests out there however is that you get
data back about metabolic factors lipids
and hormones and so forth but you don't
know what to do with those data inside
tracker solves that problem and makes it
very easy for you to understand what
sorts of nutritional behavioral maybe
even supplementation based interventions
you might want to take on and order to
adjust the numbers of those metabolic
factors hormones lipids and other things
that impact your immediate and long-term
Health to bring those numbers into the
ranges that are appropriate and indeed
optimal for you if you'd like to try
inside tracker you can visit
insidetracker.com huberman and get 20
off any of inside tracker's plans that's
inside tracker.com huberman to get 20
off let's talk for a moment about when
to avoid caffeine and in the same stroke
let's also talk about some of the myths
around caffeine for instance one of the
major myths around caffeine is that it
can increase osteoporosis
turns out that while there is a
relationship of course between calcium
and osteoporosis that is reductions in
bone density
and it is the case that caffeine can
extract calcium from certain tissues the
large-scale studies that are out there
essentially prove that if people are
ingesting enough calcium through their
diet which most everybody is although
certainly there are some people that
need to supplement calcium or make it a
point to consume more calcium-containing
foods but assuming that you are getting
adequate levels of calcium
there is no direct relationship between
caffeine intake and osteoporosis at
least not that I'm aware of I know this
was debated for a number of years in the
literature but the literature seems to
have arrived at a general consensus now
that caffeine itself is not going to
create or exacerbate osteoporosis
provided people are getting enough
calcium through their diet that is
through Foods through supplementation or
both some of the other myths around
caffeine are that for instance caffeine
will reduce testosterone levels
or will reduce estrogen levels other
myths out there
are an exact opposite to that that
caffeine will increase testosterone
levels in particular free testosterone
levels there have been some large-scale
studies addressing the hormone effects
of caffeine they are a little bit
difficult to do I should just mention
that caveat and the reason they are
difficult to do is because ninety
percent of adults are consuming caffeine
and therefore you can imagine it's very
hard to find a control group to compare
the caffeine consumers to
in particular a control group that's
well controlled for other things like
lifestyle diet exercise Etc
however when One controls as well as one
can
for all the various factors that could
impact hormones
what one discovers is that caffeine
intake at least at the dosages we talked
about earlier one to three milligrams
per kilogram of body weight
or even up to double that
there are no consistent
increases or reductions in testosterone
or estrogen in men or women that can be
directly attributed to the caffeine
intake and I say directly attributed
because in these Association studies one
always has to wonder for instance if
because people are ingesting more
caffeine they have more energy and
therefore exercising more and exercises
known to have effects on testosterone
estrogen and other hormones whether or
not the effects of caffeine on those
hormones is indirect and so on and so
forth and this all just underscores the
challenges of doing studies on humans in
the wild in their natural habitat of
living as opposed to an acute study as
it's called to bring someone into the
laboratory and studying them just for
those hours or moments
with all that said there does appear to
be a relationship between caffeine
intake and so-called sex hormone and
bonding globulin which is a protein
present in the body of both men and
women that binds to the sex steroid
hormones
testosterone and estrogen and prevents
them from being in their free or active
form
it has been shown that ingestion of
caffeine even in the sorts of dosage
ranges that are considered safe and that
we've been discussing can increase sex
hormone binding globulin such that it
can slightly reduce overall levels of
free testosterone and free estradiol in
women
now those effects are relatively minor
but they do exist if any of you are
interested in Reading further into the
effects of caffeine on hormones I'll
just refer you to a couple of studies we
will link to this in the show note
caption the title of the study is
consumption of caffeinated Beverages and
serum concentrations of sex steroid
hormones in U.S men and within this
study there's a reference to a equally
sized empowered study done on women both
of which converged on the same
conclusion by examining more than a
thousand so in this case 1410 men or
more than a thousand women that there
are increases in sex hormone binding
globulin associated with increased
intake of coffee in particular
uh but they were able to narrow that
down specifically to ingestion of
caffeine so it's not coffee per se
that's causing the increase in sex
hormone binding globulin it's actually
caffeine itself
now again the increases in sex hormone
binding globulin were not so significant
that at least to my mind they seem like
a concern although I think that it is
worth noting that if you're going to
consume caffeine that you probably want
to consume caffeine in a way that is in
dosages and with the sort of timing that
will allow you to get away with
ingesting caffeine but not to excess so
to derive the benefits of caffeine
without for instance driving up sex
hormone binding globulin too far now why
would that be a good idea why would you
want to make sure that you have enough
free testosterone and free estrogen well
some of that is related to the acute
effects of those hormones in terms of
well-being and libido and strength and
mood Etc but some of it is also relates
to the longer term effects of sex
steroid hormones many people don't
realize this but the sexoid hormones
operate on The receptors at the surface
of cells to have immediate effects but
they also can enter cells and actually
go into the nucleus of cells where the
DNA of those cells are contained and
control gene expression in those cells
so the sex Droid hormones testosterone
and estrogen are controlling a lot of
different cellular functions over long
periods of time so blunting their action
over long periods of time is probably
not a great idea but again at the
dosages of caffeine that we're talking
about today one to three milligrams per
kilogram of body weight unlikely that
the increases in sex hormone binding
globulin that one experiences from that
are going to be detrimental and
certainly the positive effects of
caffeine that one experiences in terms
of mental Performance and Physical
performance and the fact that it
increases is energy to do the sorts of
things like exercise that we know can
profoundly improve hormone profiles all
right twofold or three-fold Improvement
in hormone profiles in that case
it seems that ingesting caffeine is
overall a good thing provided it's not
in excess that also makes this the
appropriate time to mention one of the
more impressive effects of caffeine
which is on overall levels of mood and
mental health there are several studies
on this but the one that I'm
particularly fond of was published in
2019 in Psychiatry research and the
title of the paper is inverse
association between caffeine intake and
depressive symptoms in U.S adults and
these are data from the national health
and nutrition examination survey and the
basic takeaway is that while of course
there are a ton of different factors
that are going to relate to whether or
not people are depressed or not life
circumstances genetics and so on that
and here I'm quoting from the study
caffeine psychostimulant properties that
just means the ability to make us feel
more alert and positive appear to
protect against depressive symptoms and
of course they acknowledge that
additional studies are needed but this
is just one of several studies pointing
the fact that people who regularly
ingest caffeine in the appropriate dose
messages do seem to enjoy an
anti-depressive effect overall I
wouldn't want anyone to consider
caffeine a treatment for severe
depression or at least not alone a
treatment for severe depression but
provided the anxiety-inducing effects of
caffeine can be kept in check through
use of theanine or making sure that the
dosage and the timing of caffeine
ingestion is correct then caffeine
overall seems to be good for our mood
and prevent depression or at least keep
depression at Bay when depression might
otherwise surface or be more severe and
of course there are the don'ts
surrounding caffeine intake
as it relates to sleep and to put it
very simply sleep that is getting enough
quality sleep each night is the
foundation it is the Bedrock of mental
health physical health and performance
sleep and the power of sleep far exceeds
any nootropic you could ever take any
prescription drug you could ever take
any health promoting tool for your
immune system your metabolism
your mental function your physical
function you could ever take sleep is
the Bedrock I know a lot of people
experience challenge with sleep
nobody is perfect about sleep that's
important to keep in mind I think a good
goal is to get enough quality
sleep of sufficient duration eighty
percent of the nights of your life and
then as much as possible to make sure
that the remaining 20 of nights you're
not getting enough sleep for good
reasons as opposed to hard reasons good
reasons would include raising children
that's important after all every species
um desires to make more of itself and to
preserve and extend the well-being of
its young so child rearing is a
perfectly legitimate reason to get a
lack of sleep but you really want to
strive to get quality sleep most nights
of your life
which means that even if you're somebody
who can quote unquote drink an espresso
and then fall right asleep that you
avoid caffeine intake in the 12 hours
prior to sleep I realize not everyone
will be able to do that in fact I
sometimes violate that so I tend to go
to sleep around 10 pm every night
sometimes 11 occasionally 12 midnight
but usually around 10 pm every night
I confess that my last ingestion of
caffeine is not always 10 AM or prior to
that so sometimes I will have caffeine
up until 11 A.M or maybe noon and very
very rarely I'll have an afternoon
coffee or espresso
or
non-calorie containing soda or tea or
something that's of that sort but I
really tried to restrict my caffeine
intake to the early part of my day that
is before noon given that I go to sleep
around 10 pm each night and I strongly
encourage everyone out there to try and
limit their afternoon caffeine intake
this is something that Dr Matt Walker
who's an expert sleep researcher
out of University of California Berkeley
Psychology and Neuroscience Department
there author of The Incredible Book why
we sleep he's been on this podcast many
other podcasts talking about the
importance of sleep
he will remind us and I'll remind you
now that
the quarter life of caffeine is 12 hours
I mentioned this earlier but I'm going
to repeat it again and that means that
if you ingest caffeine at noon
25 percent of its effects more or less
okay I'm using broad stroke here to talk
about quarter life 25 of that is still
going to be bioactive
at midnight that night which will
disrupt the early phase of your night
the amount of slow wave sleep which then
in turn will disrupt the amount of rapid
eye movement sleep which will disrupt
your emotional processing during the
following day and so on and so forth
okay none of this is to say that if you
have the occasional cup of coffee in the
afternoon that's going to completely
demolish your sleep wake cycle forever
but I really encourage people to avoid
drinking caffeine in the 12 hours prior
to sleep and if you can't do that within
the 10 hours prior to sleep and if you
can't do that within the eight hours
prior to sleep so really try and limit
your caffeine intake in the 8 to 12
hours prior to going to sleep at night
and of course slow wave sleep AKA deep
sleep is the sleep that's associated
with somewhat mundane dreams which makes
it sound like it might not be that
important but it's also the sleep that's
associated with growth hormone release
which is important for protein synthesis
repair of all bodily tissues and
metabolism and slow wave sleep is also
critically attached to your immune
system's ability to clear out bacteria
and viruses that might otherwise infect
your tissues now I'd like to talk about
caffeine and performance and that
includes both mental Performance and
Physical performance
now I'd like to talk about caffeine and
its positive effects on performance when
used correctly and here we are referring
to both mental Performance and Physical
performance
the exploration of caffeine as a pro
Performance Tool has been explored since
the 1930s at least at some of the
earliest documented literature on this
although I have to imagine given that
people have been using caffeine for much
longer than that that long ago somebody
realized that by ingesting a certain
plant that they felt much more alertness
and were able to hunt and gather or do
any number of different things better
and as a consequence decide to consume
more of that plant
these days we consume a lot of caffeine
in the form of coffee and tea mainly and
some people consume it in the form of
caffeine tablets or energy drinks Etc
across the board one finds that caffeine
intake at a level of one to three
milligrams per kilogram of body weight
improves reaction time that is it
reduces the amount of time to take a
physical action or to answer a question
correctly
with a verbal response it can also
improve coordination it can also improve
memory although I do want to mention
that whereas most studies of the effects
of caffeine on improving mental and
physical performance
involve taking caffeine at one to three
milligrams per kilogram of body weight
before the mental task or physical task
there is also a pro performance effect
of caffeine on memory if one takes
caffeine after
learning certain material or I should
say being exposed to certain material
we'll come back to that in a few minutes
if one examines Reaction Time mood
alertness
Focus
and memory where the ability to call up
information from memory or
physical dexterity power output
endurance
and overall feelings of well-being
during exercise and exertion
caffeine has been shown in numerous
studies in both men and women to improve
all of those metrics significantly
so this is all just to say that caffeine
is an incredible performance enhancing
tool now what's not obvious from the
statement that caffeine is a performance
enhancing tool across the board and in
men and women and in different contexts
is that the way in which caffeine is
taken is very important
because ninety percent or more of adults
consume caffeine
finding controls for studies of caffeine
is really challenging that is finding
people who don't ingest caffeine
regularly is a very challenging task for
the researcher and as a consequence many
of the studies of caffeine on human
beings involve depriving regular
caffeine users of caffeine
and then examining the effects of
caffeine given after a period of say
five to fifteen days of abstinence in a
person that is essentially experiencing
mild withdrawal symptoms because they
haven't had the caffeine that they were
used to getting so this is an important
point and it's a point that likely
exacerbates The observed Pro performance
effects of caffeine now all of that
isn't necessarily a problem provided you
keep it in mind
and it actually points to a way in which
even if you're a regular caffeine user
you can extract more of the benefits of
caffeine the simplest way to do this for
instance is to look back to what we
talked about earlier in terms of the
need to have most of your cortisol
increase restricted to the hour or hours
just after waking in terms of mood and
alertness and performance
one of the ways to increase the peak of
that cortisol early in the day is to
consume caffeine shortly after that Peak
occurs
and this was really nicely demonstrated
in a study entitled caffeine stimulation
of cortisol secretion across the waking
hours in relation to caffeine intake
levels we will provide a link to this
study it's a somewhat complicated study
because they looked at a bunch of
different times of day for caffeine
intake
and I should mention this study they
used this 300 milligrams per day or 600
milligrams per day so that's quite High
although for people of sufficient body
weight and who are accustomed to taking
caffeine it's certainly not going to be
in excess of what a lot of people out
there are taking but basically what they
observed was the following
cortisol responses to caffeine are
reduced but not eliminated in people who
consume caffeine on a daily basis what
this means is that if you wake up and as
I recommended earlier you avoid drinking
caffeine for the first 90 to 120 minutes
after waking but you do get some
sunlight or other bright light in your
eyes in that time maybe even get some
exercise in that time which would be
even better and then you ingest caffeine
you'll get a further increase in
cortisol which
provided it's restricted to the early
part of the day is a good thing overall
for mood and alertness so this is a
simple performance enhancing tool which
is to stack caffeine on the tail of that
early cortisol Peak I should also
mention however that in this study they
had people do a five-day caffeine
abstinence prior to being tested with
300 milligrams or 600 milligrams of
caffeine so the simple tool to extract
from this and other studies like it is
that if you want to experience the
maximum alertness promoting effects of
caffeine when you ingest it early in the
day
you would abstain from caffeine for five
days and then ingest caffeine 90 to 120
minutes after waking I would still hope
that you were doing all the other things
that I described morning sunlight
exercise Etc correctly but regardless
it's very clear that a five-day
abstinence from caffeine however painful
that might be will increase the
performance enhancing effects of
caffeine when you take caffeine on that
sixth day now I'm sure many of you out
there are saying why would I ever want
to abstain from caffeine for five days
in order to just get this six day
performance enhancing effect well there
are a couple reasons for doing that
perhaps you're planning to travel to a
new time zone and you want to use
caffeine as a stimulant to stay up
during the day in the new time zone
that's a somewhat unusual case others of
you might be interested in the Pro
physical performance effects of caffeine
we'll talk more about these in a little
bit but you want to get the maximum
strength increase or the maximum
endurance increase from ingesting in
this case 300 to 600 milligrams
of caffeine well in that case abstaining
from caffeine for five days will greatly
exacerbate the pro performance effects
of caffeine when you take it on that
sixth day although admittedly those five
days are likely to be pretty painful if
you're a regular caffeine user another
variation on this however might be to
have the amount of caffeine that you
ingest on a daily basis and then go back
to your regular level of caffeine intake
on that day in which you need the
caffeine to really boost your mood
energy and performance another reason
why you might want to abstain from
caffeine or reduce your caffeine intake
for a period of time and then go back to
your regular caffeine intake is simply
to identify how much of an effect
caffeine is really having on your
overall level of daily functioning and
mood this was something that was
actually covered in beautiful detail in
a book by Michael Pollan all about
caffeine it's available on Audible I
really enjoyed that book
it describes his experience with the
decision to completely abstain from
caffeine for a period of months although
I confessed that after hearing that book
what it basically made me want to do is
never quit drinking caffeine because it
sounded as if at least my interpretation
was that even after several weeks or
months of abstaining from caffeine that
he still fantasized about the effects of
caffeine but he did mention that when
returning to ingesting caffeine after a
period of long abstinence that it had
almost a uh let's not call it a
psychedelic property but it had such
obvious effects on mood and alertness
and feelings of well-being that it
really highlighted for him the extent to
which caffeine normally was allowing him
to just function what he thought was
normally so in other words many of us
don't even really know what our normal
basal level of cognitive and physical
functioning is because we're ingesting
caffeine on such a regular basis I
confess that that as much as I enjoyed
that book and as intriguing as his
description of caffeine abstinence and
then the return to caffeine was I don't
intend to ever find out personally now a
very good reason why you might want to
abstain from caffeine for a deliberate
period of time and then return to
caffeine intake is for its physical
performance enhancing effects and here
we can look to a really interesting
study
title of which is time course of
tolerance to the performance effects of
caffeine and what I like about this
study is that while yes it does say that
abstaining from caffeine and then
returning to caffeine intake can enhance
physical performance in a very specific
way it also says that if you take
caffeine regularly you can still see the
physical performance enhancing effects
of caffeine although they are not quite
as robust
as they would be had you abstained from
caffeine
the design of the study is pretty
straightforward they had people either
ingest three milligrams per kilogram of
caffeine for 20 consecutive days many
people are already doing that I realized
but they had people do that or ensure
that they were doing that or others
ingested a placebo for 20 days so they
abstained from caffeine without
realizing it
then after that 20 days of either
ingesting caffeine or a placebo
their Peak Performance was measured in
terms of aerobic output but prior to
that measurement they had caffeine okay
so it's 20 days of caffeine and then a
21st day of caffeine and then the
physical task on that 21st day or it's
20 days of abstinence from caffeine and
then on day 21 you get caffeine and you
get the same physical test and what they
discovered was that the ingestion of
caffeine increased Peak Performance in
this aerobic output
dramatically if people had abstained
from caffeine
but for people that had consumed
caffeine all the way through up until
that day it still was effective to
ingest caffeine on day 21 but not as
effective
as it would have been had they abstained
and in fact the magnitude of the what
they call
ergogenic effect which is the pro
performance enhancing effect of caffeine
was higher on the first day than in
subsequent days when they allowed people
to continue caffeine intake so the
takeaway from the study is really
straightforward if you want to get the
maximum physical performance enhancing
effects of caffeine you abstain from
caffeine for 20 days then on day 21 when
you're going to do the physical thing
the task you ingest caffeine about 30
minutes to an hour before you do that
physical challenge
now 20 days of abstinence is going to be
rough for a lot of people I certainly
don't want to sign up for this study
in which case you might want to do five
days of abstinence as we talked about
before and then on day six is the day
that you ingest caffeine and do the
physical task
there are even some studies showing that
you can abstain from caffeine for just
two days for just 48 hours and in
particular if you are a regular user of
caffeine this allows you to on day three
ingest caffeine at the dose that's
appropriate for you and do the physical
or I should mention mental performance
task and perform significantly better
than those that have been taking
caffeine throughout the entire period
leading up to the challenge
so you don't necessarily need to abstain
for 20 days in order to get the pro
performance effects of caffeine on day
21 you could do five days of abstinence
prior or even two days of abstinence
prior or if that's intolerable to you as
it is in my mind to me to just reduce
your caffeine intake slightly or even
perhaps have it if you can tolerate that
in the week or two weeks or maybe even
three weeks preceding some physical or
mental challenge now again this sort of
implies that you're going up against a
marathon or you're going up against
a series of long tests maybe
standardized tests in one day there I
just really want to point out that there
is an abundant literature showing that
people perform best on mental tests if
they are in the state
that they were when they studied for
that material now in college I knew a
number of people who took this to the
extreme thinking that if they were to
study under the effects of alcohol that
they would be best off consuming alcohol
prior to taking exams and it turns out
to not be the case here we're talking in
particular about psychostimulant effects
of caffeine and other compounds so don't
think that you can drink or be under the
influence of THC and then take when you
study and then take an exam under the
same influence and do just as well as
you would had you not ingested anything
please don't let that be the takeaway
however
do Let It Be the takeaway that
caffeine's effects are made more potent
by a brief to not so brief period of
abstinence prior to taking a dosage of
caffeine and then the final point to
make is that if you are somebody who is
not accustomed to drinking caffeine
meaning you're hypersensitive to
caffeine or you don't regularly ingest
caffeine please do not ingest caffeine
on the day of any important mental or
physical challenge or performance
because what you will find is that
because you are not caffeine adapted you
will experience changes in your thermal
regulation
in your levels of anxiety and
jitteriness and your levels of focus
that could be very detrimental to mental
or physical performance so you don't
want to throw yourself in the deep end
um by ingesting caffeine if you're not
used to it and I should mention that for
people that are not accustomed to
ingesting caffeine or are very sensitive
to caffeine even 25 to 50 milligrams of
caffeine in the amount that's found in
for instance a piece of certain types of
chocolate can actually cause anxiety so
be careful there here I'm referring only
to people that are accustomed with
caffeine intake so what I recommend is
to explore the ergogenic effects of
caffeine during your training and then
to make a decision about what you can
reasonably and reliably do in terms of
abstinence and then
pulsed with caffeine on the day of the
challenge I get a lot of questions as to
whether or not caffeine has different
effects on the nervous system and on
performance in particular depending on
phases of the menstrual cycle
so I explored that in my research for
this episode and I found two studies
both of which we will reference in the
show note captions the first one is
entitled
caffeine consumption and menstrual
function so it's actually the
relationship between caffeine and
menstrual function we will do an entire
episode about the menstrual cycle
menstrual function but the other one as
it relates to Performance was published
in 2020
in the European Journal of nutrition
which is ergogenic effects of caffeine
on pic aerobic cycling power during the
menstrual cycle and the basic takeaway
of this study is
frankly a very nice study showed that
quote caffeine increased Peak aerobic
cycling power in the early follicular
pre-ovulatory and mid-luteal phases of
the menstrual cycle thus the ingestion
and again here they use three milligrams
of caffeine per kilogram of body mass
might be considered an ergogenic
aid for women who are in the menstrual
cycle during all three phases of their
cycle so keep that in mind women
for those of you that are regular users
of caffeine or you're using caffeine to
enhance physical performance there does
not seem to be any menstrual cycle phase
dependent effects of caffeine on
performance that is caffeine seems to
always increase physical performance
regardless of the phase of the menstrual
cycle you might happen to be in I'd like
to touch on a little bit more of the use
of caffeine for enhancing mental
performance yes it is the case
that ingesting one to three milligrams
of caffeine per kilogram of body weight
in the 30 minutes or so prior to doing a
memory task or sitting down to doing
some studying or learning of any kind
physical or mental performance of any
kind is beneficial for all the reasons
we talked about before related to
dopamine and acetylcholine Etc
but it turns out that it is also the
case that spiking one's adrenaline and
other so-called catecholamines so this
would be dopamine norepinephrine and
epinephrine after about of learning can
greatly enhance memory for the
information that one was trying to learn
that's right spiking your adrenaline
after learning can greatly increase
memory for the material you're trying to
learn in fact this is a practice that
dates back centuries and was written
about in a beautiful annual review of
Neuroscience on the biology of memory by
James McGaw where he talks about
medieval practices of children being
taught information and then being thrown
literally into cold water to stimulate
the release of adrenaline and that
increase in in Adrenaline while the
mechanism wasn't completely understood
it was understood that that sort of
shock to the system from the cold water
led to better memory and retention of
the information that these children had
been exposed to and it turns out the
exact same thing is true for adults in
the laboratory or kids in the laboratory
and here I'm not suggesting throwing
anyone into cold water if you want to
get into cold water there's a reason we
call it deliberate cold exposure on the
podcast is that it should be deliberate
and controlled by you not by somebody
else if it's controlled by somebody else
that might be you know military
screening or something but
here we're talking about deliberately
increasing your levels of adrenaline and
other catecholamines dopamine
norepinephrine Etc
you can do that certainly by deliberate
cold exposure with a cold shower or
getting in up to your neck in cold water
of any kind but the other way to do that
is to spike your adrenaline by ingesting
a one to three milligrams per kilogram
of
caffeine after sitting down to try and
learn some material I confessed it more
often than not I use caffeine the same
way that most people use it which is
okay I'm going to sit down I'm gonna
research information for a podcast or
assemble some information for a paper or
Grant and I want to focus so I will
drink a cup of coffee
at the beginning of that and maybe even
throughout that or a couple year of a
mate at the beginning or throughout that
or I'll sip on one or both
throughout trying to learn and that
works quite well
in terms of maintaining focus and
alertness and
retention of information but it is
indeed the case that is the research
supports the fact and I've experienced
the fact that if I abstain from caffeine
while I'm trying to learn something but
then I drink caffeine immediately after
somewhat surprisingly to me but
certainly in a way that's consistent
with the research literature
memory for the information that I was
focused on prior to ingesting that
caffeine is much greater and here I'm
talking about it as a personal anecdote
but this is actually what the data point
to both in animals and in humans and if
you think about it makes perfect sense
because the way that the memory systems
of the brain are organized is that we go
through life experiencing things we
encounter surprises both good and bad we
go through the motions of things both
typical mundane exciting and
and novel and not novel
and then every once in a while something
will happen that will Spike our
catecholamines dopamine typically if
it's a positive surprise
adrenaline which can be associated with
both positive surprise or positive
events and negative events
or surprises and
without fail increases in the
catecholamines tend to lock in memories
for things that preceded the increase in
those catecholamines again the
catecholamines being dopamine
epinephrine and norepinephrine sometimes
all three in combinations sometimes just
two of those sometimes just one of those
depending on the experience
so it makes perfect sense that using
caffeine at the end of a learning bout
would enhance our memory for the
information that we're trying to learn
so if you decide that you want to try
and extract this performance enhancing
effect of caffeine what I recommend
would be
to try and abstain from caffeine for a
day or two prior but if you can't just
continue with your normal caffeine
intake but then when you sit down to
study or learn something to not ingest
any caffeine as you do that but then
afterward to ingest caffeine now in
theory you could probably further
enhance the memory encoding effects of
adrenaline and the other catecholamines
by drinking caffeine and then taking a
cold shower doing deliberate cold
exposure if you really wanted to or had
the ability to or doing some sort of
intense form of exercise and we'll talk
in a moment about how caffeine exercise
on the adrenaline system interact but as
a brief but relevant aside brief bouts
of intense exercise ranging from 10 to
50 minutes or so have been shown to
improve memory for information that one
was trying to learn prior to the intense
exercise this is work from Dr Wendy
Suzuki's Lab at NYU as well as other
Laboratories some of the work that's
being done at Stanford and the Mind Body
Laboratories
and our laboratory points in the
direction of these kinds of effects as
well
they all come back to the same general
neurochemical theme which is that when
we experience an increase in these
catecholamines that include adrenaline
dopamine and norepinephrine
the memory systems of the brain flip on
in a way that try to capture the
information and the perceptions and the
experiences that we were exposed to just
prior to the increase in catecholamines
and caffeine but also exercise and also
cold water and of course any of those
alone are in combination
all increased the levels of
catecholamines so it makes perfect
logical mechanistic sense as to why this
would work and in fact it does work if
you want to remember specific
information you might consider using
caffeine As you move through and absorb
and are exposed to that information but
you might also consider using caffeine
after being exposed to that information
because studies in animals and humans
show that that is a potent way to
increase memory for what you were just
exposed to I should mention that what I
just described also pushes back on
something that I know a number of people
perhaps have heard about and maybe even
use which is this notion of the
nappacino I remember hearing about this
a few years back it was a sort of trend
if you will the trend involved drinking
a cup of coffee or double espresso and
then going down for a nap typically in
the afternoon and then waking up and the
idea was that the caffeine would hit
your system right at the time that you
awake from the nap and that you would be
better able to focus and exercise
there are a couple things about that
practice that I don't like first of all
it implies in most cases that you're
napping and ingesting caffeine in the
afternoon which I realize for many
students
and for people that are comfortable
staying up until the wee hours of the
night and then waking up late the next
day might be compatible with their
schedule but again because of the Sleep
diminishing effects of caffeine
and we talked about earlier I'm not
crazy about the idea of people ingesting
caffeine in the late afternoon in order
to perform better in the late afternoon
far better would be to restrict caffeine
intake to the early part of the day as
we talked about earlier the other reason
is that the data on things like
non-sleep deep rest
and naps in the afternoon and again the
rule here is that you don't have to nap
but if you want an app it's been shown
that naps of 90 minutes or less or
non-sleep deep rest protocols and you
can find those for instance there's one
with me speaking you just put nsdr
huberman into YouTube you can hear that
it's completely zero cost there are
other nstr scripts out there now of
course if you prefer those
that those can all lead to increases in
one of the catecholamines at least which
is dopamine
that's been shown in a really nice
neurotransmitter labeling study not from
my laboratory but from another
laboratory but also can improve mood
focus and alertness on its own without
the need to ingest caffeine prior to
going into those States and in fact
ingesting caffeine prior to a nap or
ingesting caffeine prior to nsdr is most
certainly going to reduce the
effectiveness of that nap in nsdr in
restoring natural levels of alertness
and focus that would lead to the
performance enhancing effect so I'm not
such a fan of the so-called nappacino
although if any of you out there have
derived great benefit from it definitely
let me know your protocol and what
you've experienced put it in the uh
comment section if you would I'd
appreciate that there's another very
important and potent use of caffeine for
enhancing performance and this relates
not just to the dopamine and epinephrine
and the arousal inducing effects of
caffeine and it doesn't even just relate
to the
effect of caffeine on enhancing frontal
lobe function it does include all that
but it also includes those reinforcing
effects of caffeine that we talked about
at the beginning of the episode and the
best way to illustrate these performance
enhancing effects of caffeine that stem
directly from its association with
reinforcement is to highlight a study
and the title of the study is blood
dopamine level enhanced by caffeine in
men after treadmill running and as the
title suggests this was carried out in
men but there's no reason to think that
the same results wouldn't also be
present in women there are some sex
dependent effects of caffeine I'll touch
on just briefly at the end but those are
largely present in kids that is
adolescents and teens as opposed to
adults
so this study is really interesting what
they had people do was run on a
treadmill and either ingest caffeine
again three milligrams per kilogram of
body weight or to not ingest caffeine
and then they looked at levels of
dopamine and other neurotransmitters and
hormones such as prolactin and cortisol
and the basic takeaway is as the title
suggests that exercise while on its own
can increase cortisol in healthy ways
provided it's not too intense and too
long
little note here if you have trouble
recovering from exercise or you want to
continue to derive the benefits from
exercise
in general best not to do high intensity
exercise for longer than 75 minutes or
90 minutes probably being the outer
threshold I realize that there are some
genetic freaks out there or people that
are chemically assisted that can recover
from very intense long bouts of exercise
but most people don't do well through
long bouts of intense exercise on a
regular basis and limiting their intense
exercise to 60 Minutes or Less that
doesn't include the warm-up is going to
be beneficial see the episode on a
toolkit for Fitness if you'd like
details on that
exercise is known to increase levels of
dopamine cortisol and other
catecholamines and neurotransmitters
very potently and things like
testosterone and estrogen in ways that
we know are beneficial to us and of
course have all these positive effects
on the musculoskeletal system and
cardiovascular effects but unbeknownst
to most people
ingesting three milligrams per kilogram
of caffeine prior to exercise further
increases the dopamine release
associated with exercise specifically
and this has two important effects first
of all that increase in dopamine is
great because it provides a long lasting
increase in focus alertness and
motivation not just during the exercise
but also after the exercise and second
it that is caffeine and dopamine in
combination act as a reinforcer to make
the experience of exercise end the
period immediate after exercise more
pleasant and in fact reinforcing so in
other words one way to enjoy exercise
more and to enjoy the activities that
follow exercise more and to experience a
genuine increase in dopamine that's
beneficial for mood and alertness is to
ingest caffeine prior to exercise now
this is important because a number of
people out there are exercising love
exercise
love eating great love doing all the
things that are beneficial for their
health but a number of people out there
really don't like to exercise and that
serves as a serious block for their
willingness and their consistency to
exercise
ingesting caffeine gives us energy to
exercise it increases the release of
neurochemicals and hormones that are
good for us during exercise but as I'm
highlighting here it also increases the
reinforcement Pathways associated with
exercise that is it creates a positive
feeling about the general theme of
engaging in exercise and
it creates a general positive experience
of the things that follow exercise so I
think this if nothing else is a call for
or support for the idea that ingesting
caffeine as a performance enhancing tool
makes perfect sense but for those out
there that don't enjoy exercise in
particular certain forms of exercise
ingesting caffeine can change your
relationship to that exercise in other
words make it more positive much in the
same way that ingesting caffeine
alongside a certain taste that would
otherwise be neutral or maybe even
negative can actually make the taste of
that particular drink or food positive
so again this brings us back to the
reinforcing properties of caffeine that
are subconscious it's not just about the
enhanced performance in the test or the
enhanced performance on the treadmill or
with the weights in the gym it's
enhanced feelings of mood and well-being
that are genuine because of the effect
of caffeine on certain neurotransmitter
and hormone systems but it also is
creating an overall milieu of
reinforcing all of the things that led
into occur during and occur after
exercise I do want to point out
something that's very important as it
relates to combining things like
caffeine and exercise in order to
increase dopamine this is something that
came up in the episode that I did on
dopamine motivation and drive which
turns out to be one of our most popular
episodes again you can find that at
hubermanlab.com and links to all formats
with timestamps Etc this also came up in
the episode on ADHD because of the
relationship between ADHD and dopamine
and that's this notion of dopamine
stacking
in the episode on dopamine motivation
and drive I pointed out that while there
are a near infinite number of things
that can increase dopamine release
most notably positive surprise or
positive anticipation or experiencing a
win
um certainly there are compounds both
drugs of abuse food sex and certain
supplements that can increase dopamine
to varying levels and to varying degrees
both healthy and unhealthy that's all
contained in that episode on dopamine
motivation to drive but what I pointed
out is that if you are somebody who
tends to experience
difficulty with motivation that
so-called dopamine stacking as I called
it might be something that you want to
avoid what does dopamine stacking
dopamine stacking would be combining you
know a highly caffeinated energy drink
that also includes the amino acid
tyrosine which is a precursor to
dopamine plus Loud Music Plus getting
yourself really ramped up then an
intense workout all of that can be great
if you do it every once in a while but
what you will quickly find is that the
extent to which your dopamine Peaks also
dictates the extent to which your
dopamine will drop after that Peak and
when I say drop I mean drop below
Baseline so a lot of people find that if
they stack a lot of things to Peak their
dopamine
that then they experience a low and it
does take some time for them to return
to Baseline and I highly recommend not
engaging in activities or consuming
compounds that
are in an attempt to accelerate that
return to Baseline because all it will
do is drive that Baseline lower and
lower
so this requires being able to tolerate
a drop in dopamine Baseline for a period
of time Etc
now the reason I'm bringing this up now
in the context of this caffeine episode
is I just described a study in which
using caffeine prior to exercise
increases dopamine after exercise and so
you might be saying especially if you
heard that earlier episode wait isn't
that dopamine stacking aren't you
encouraging me to stack my dopamine well
in some sense yes but keep in mind I'm
not suggesting that you do this every
time you exercise so just as in that
earlier episode I emphasized the fact
that while stacking multiple stimuli
right caffeine or energy drinks and
music and Etc
for exercise or for mental work or for
any experience for that matter is okay
to do every once in a while for most
people you don't want to get in the
habit of doing it consistently every
time you exercise or every time you go
out for instance and so you really want
to be cautious that is you want to
protect your both Baseline levels of
dopamine and your Peak levels of
dopamine that said for people that want
to experience an increase in mood
alertness and performance or who want to
condition themselves because that's
really what it is it's conditioning
Yourself by the reinforcing effects of
dopamine to
increase your liking or maybe even your
loving of exercise occasionally using
caffeine or frequently using caffeine
prior to exercise is fine but be very
careful and by being very careful what I
mean is pay attention to how you feel in
the hours and days after that dopamine
increase wears off so for instance if
you ingest caffeine and then exercise
very intensely and you're feeling great
afterwards but then eight hours later or
the next day you're feeling a little bit
low I suggest you don't go back and do
the exact same thing right away I would
give you yourself a little bit of time
to let that Baseline of dopamine return
to normal
so again stacking different things
chemical and behavioral in order to
increase dopamine can be done in a safe
way that's beneficial to you depending
on your goals but be careful about not
stacking too many stimuli for dopamine
too often that's the key early in the
episode I mentioned one possible
caffeine-consuming schedule that works
very well that doesn't fortunately
subject you to uh long 20-day bouts or
five day or even two day ballots of
abstinence and that's the Every Other
Day schedule of caffeine if you look at
the half-life of caffeine and you look
at its effects on the dopamine system
and its performance enhancing effects
and how a period of abstinence can in
fact increase the performance enhancing
effects of caffeine but also take into
consideration that caffeine can be habit
forming and we can develop a sort of
tolerance to caffeine well then what
emerges from all of that is that
being a person who consumes caffeine
every other day can actually help you
maximize most of the positive effects of
caffeine without subjecting you to the
kind of misery that occurs if you're
accustomed to consuming caffeine every
single day and then suddenly go into a
two or five or Twenty day abstinence So
I myself have never tried in every other
day caffeine approach
although I'm considering doing it based
on the literature that I've read and I'm
considering doing it in a very specific
way which would be to only consume
caffeine on the days in which I
resistance train and since I tend to do
that about three or four days per week
organized in a way that's every other
day again if you want to see the
exercise schedule that I follow
including cardiovascular exercise and
weight training and all the reasons and
rationale for what I do and how it maps
on to the scientific literature related
to health span and lifespan Vitality Etc
you can find that at hubermanlab.com and
we had a toolkit for Fitness that ought
to be posted to our website before long
the Every Other Day schedule of caffeine
intake to me seems like the most
rational one if one wants to maximize on
the performance enhancing effects of
caffeine without suffering the effects
of caffeine withdrawal that are
associated with being a regular consumer
of caffeine and then stopping caffeine
intake such as headache and irritability
and so forth not I nor anyone in my life
wants me to experience those effects and
I'm sure you don't want to experience
those effects for you either so if
you're somebody that decides to try the
every other day protocol or you are
somebody who's already doing that
protocol please let me know what your
experiences with that are at least by my
read of the literature on caffeine and
its performance enhancing effects but
also the effects of caffeine on
neurotransmitter and hormone systems
the Every Other Day caffeine's schedule
does seem to be the most rational and
scientifically grounded one in order to
maximize on all those effects in
addition to so-called performance
enhancing effects of caffeine there are
also the well-studied and now fairly
well mechanistically understood
pro-health effects of caffeine now here
when I talk about pro-health effects of
caffeine I want to be very clear that if
your schedule of caffeine intake that is
your timing of caffeine intake or
anything else for that matter
offsets getting regular high quality
sleep of sufficient duration well then
you are undermining the pro-health
effects of that thing this is true for
exercise this is true for caffeine this
is true for supplementation this is true
for prescription drugs again you don't
want to be neurotically attached to the
idea that you have to get perfect sleep
every night because that's simply not
true but it is absolutely the case that
anything whether or not it's good for
you or bad for you in the short term
that disrupts your sleep because of the
timing in which you're doing that thing
is going to undermine your immediate and
long-term Health before long so with
that said
there are several well-described Health
promoting effects of caffeine ingestion
and once again when I say caffeine
ingestion I'm referring to that one to
three milligrams per kilogram of body
weight dosage
there are really nice studies showing
that being a regular consumer of
caffeine can help offset some of the
probability sum of the probability of
developing Parkinson's and maybe
Alzheimer's related dementia as well
these are not terribly controversial
data because of the fact that caffeine
is known to increase the release of
those catecholamines
dopamine epinephrine and norepinephrine
as well as acetylcholine all those
neurotransmitter and neuromodulator
systems are the ones that are known to
be defective in Parkinson's and
Alzheimer's although there are other
transmitter and hormone systems that are
defective as well
there are beautiful reviews on the
neuroprotective effects of caffeine and
neurodegenerative diseases
they're quite extensive and I'll just
refer you to one and the references
they're in and we'll provide a link to
this in the show note captions the title
as the
topic at hand suggests is the
neuroprotective effects of caffeine and
neurodegenerative diseases this was
published in 2016. I'm sure there have
been other reviews since then but it
includes many many quality references on
studies both in animals and in humans
pointing to the fact that specific
enzymes that are associated with the
health of in particular dopamine neurons
or made more robust by regular ingestion
of caffeine
it also points to the fact that the
increase in dopamine receptors that is
induced by regular ingestion of caffeine
that I referred to earlier is another
way in which dopamine however many
dopamine neurons remain around in people
with Parkinson's or people who are aging
that lose dopamine neurons naturally
that dopamine can have its maximal
effect because of the increase in
receptors for dopamine that caffeine
induces
and there are other biological
mechanisms that further support why
caffeine ought to be neuroprotective
including its effects on the
acetylcholine system which is one of the
major systems disrupted in Alzheimer's
dementia so in other words it makes
perfect sense as to why caffeine would
be neuroprotective caffeine has also
been shown to diminish headache
particularly when taken in combination
with aspirin and that's because of the
effects of caffeine and aspirin on blood
flow there's also evidence that caffeine
can provide brief but substantial relief
from asthma so I wouldn't want people to
rely on caffeine as a life
saving approach to an asthmatic attack
that said for people that suffer from
minor asthma that caffeine intake again
of the dosages that we talked about
before has been shown to alleviate some
of the major symptoms of asthma for
anywhere from one to four hours
and I know this is of relevance to a lot
of people out there
because caffeine increases the
catecholamines and in particular because
caffeine increases dopamine Transmission
in the prefrontal cortex this area of
the brain is associated with focus and
Rule setting and context and task
switching
caffeine is known to improve focus and
alertness in particular in people who
have symptoms of
ADHD or other attention and focus issues
now caffeine alone does not appear to be
as potent for the treatment of ADHD as
are things like Ritalin Adderall
modafinil and arm modafinil and vivance
if you would like a sort of head-by-head
comparison of
prescription drugs supplements and
things like caffeine as well as coverage
of Behavioral tools and nutritional
tools Etc that can positively offset
some of the symptoms of ADHD please see
the episode that I did on ADHD again
that's available at hubermanlab.com in
all formats but that said caffeine does
increase focus and it does it through a
number of different mechanisms not the
least of which is to increase dopamine
Transmission in the forebrain just as a
drug like ritalin or Adderall would
although not to the same extent as a
drug like ritalin or Adderall does
before we close today I do want to just
briefly return to the reinforcing
effects of caffeine that we talked about
earlier this study on the honeybees that
showed that bees prefer certain nectares
because they contain caffeine even
though they are not aware that those
nectares contain caffeine they just come
to like the feeling that those nectares
provide them so much that they associate
that in a subconscious way with the
flowers themselves and they come to like
those flowers or human beings for
instance children that ingest
caffeinated beverages come to adore the
taste of those Beverages and beautiful
Studies have been done that describe how
children and adults truly cannot
distinguish between the taste of a
caffeinated and non-caffeinated beverage
and caffeine can be placed into
essentially any beverage in order to
give us a preference for that beverage
or food in fact the studies have been
done with yogurt if you put caffeine
into yogurt
of different flavors even plain yogurt
which most kids don't like they will
come to prefer whatever flavor contain
the caffeine even if then you remove the
caffeine from that Flavor now eventually
their preference for that flavor will be
extinguished but all of this is just to
say that so many of the things that we
like whether or not it's coffee or tea
or a given flavor of food or a given
experience or even exercise
occur because we ingest caffeine in
conjunction with those activities now
these are not tricks that your nervous
system plays on you these are real
neurochemical reinforcing effects and I
think that we would all do well to think
about and to leverage these reinforcing
effects much in the same way we would do
well to think about
and hopefully not leverage aversive
effects of certain compounds right the
simple way to put this is
I or anyone could get you to dislike
something someone or someplace by making
you feel slightly less good lower mood
I don't even have to make you feel
nauseous but less good
after ingesting something or having a
certain kind of interaction or being in
a certain environment very
straightforward to do that because of
the way that your nervous system is
wired for conditioning
however there's the positive side of all
this which is that it's very
straightforward to reinforce the
experience of a given food including its
taste but all the context around it the
container the texture the people you
consume it with where you consume it Etc
for instance I wonder why we are not
pairing caffeine with broccoli and here
I'm not suggesting that people actually
do that experiment or play that trick on
people but
you have to sort of imagine that if
caffeine is this incredible reinforcer
of all sorts of things in particular
things that we ingest and would want to
ingest more of if it's paired with
caffeine well then you actually can use
caffeine as a tool to increase
reinforcement of different things and
you can avoid caffeine as a way to
further reinforce things that you would
like to stop and here I'd like to just
give the example of sugar Cravings a lot
of people ask me how do I avoid sugar
Cravings I've talked about the use of
L-glutamine for that I've talked about
making sure you're getting enough
essential fatty acids and essential
amino acids
as a way to reduce sugar cravings
please note however that if you are
somebody who likes to have your
sugar whether or not it's a piece of
chocolate or your dessert Etc I'm not
saying that's bad but if you're trying
to reduce your sugar cravings
ask yourself are you ingesting sugar
along with caffeine could be the
caffeine contained in that Sugar
containing food like chocolate or it
could be that you're having a cup of
coffee along with your pastry and then
you're struggling with sugar Cravings
well think about it you're not just
being reinforced by the sugar and the
effects of sugar on dopamine which are
real and both conscious and subconscious
through the gut to the brain dopamine
system and Direct on the brain dopamine
system but by co-ingesting caffeine you
are also further enhancing the
reinforcing effects of sugar
the flip side to all of this is that you
could use caffeine as a way to increase
your appetite for certain things I
actually know somebody I won't reveal
who this person is but they are quite
prominent podcaster who ingests 125 to
150 milligrams of caffeine in tablet
form in tablet form along with herbal
tea and use this as a way to develop a
preference for herbal tea because they
found that coffee was giving them other
effects that weren't good for them so it
works quite well in animals and it works
quite well in insects and it works quite
well in humans I suppose animals insects
and humans are all animals at the end of
the day so no surprise there but it all
underscores a sense to which caffeine is
an absolutely fascinating molecule I
mean it's a ability to offset the
sleepiness system if you will this
adenosine system and to control our
schedules in that way to essentially
take a withdrawal against the bank that
is adenosine and then pay that back
later in the form of getting sleepy
later as opposed to when we want to be
alert its ability to enhance focus
alertness and mood and if taken after
trying to learn something and remember
it to enhance memory especially and its
ability to increase VO2 max increase
strength we didn't even talk today about
it but I'll just briefly mention that
caffeine ingested in the sorts of doses
we talked about earlier because its
effects on the neuromuscular system and
the calcium system associated with
neuromuscular
exertion and fatigue can increase Peak
power output and muscle contractability
so it's enhancing performance there as
well and of course caffeine does a
number of other things just generally
related to overall and basal level of
mood and alertness not the least of
which are these increases in dopamine so
caffeine is really an incredible
molecule it's affecting all these
various neurotransmitter systems but not
haphazardly it's increasing dopamine and
acetylcholine in the forebrain to
increase attention it's reducing fatigue
it's improving mental and physical
performance for some obvious and some
not so obvious reasons and what I think
is among the more miraculous and
Powerful effects of caffeine it is a
potent potent potent reinforcer of
things Foods people and experiences and
it's one that you can leverage in any
direction that you like once you
understand the way that caffeine exerts
those reinforcing properties so today
I've really tried to cover as much as I
could about the mechanisms of caffeine
action in the brain and body as well as
tools and schedules and dosages in which
you can leverage caffeine in order to
meet your physical performance mental
performance and frankly mental health
and overall health goals if you're
learning from and are enjoying this
podcast please subscribe to our YouTube
channel that's a terrific 0 zero cost
way to support us in addition please
subscribe to the podcast on both Spotify
and apple and on both Spotify and apple
you can leave us up to a five star
review if you have questions for us or
comments about the podcast or guests
that you'd like me to interview on The
huberman Lab podcast please put those in
the comments section on YouTube we do
read all the comments in addition please
check out the sponsors mentioned at the
beginning and throughout today's episode
that's the best way to support this
podcast if you're not already following
huberman lab on social media we are
huberman lab on all platforms so that's
Instagram Twitter LinkedIn and Facebook
and all of those places I describe
science and science related tools some
of which overlap with the contents of
the huberman Lab podcast but much of
which is distinct from content on the
huberman Lab podcast so again it's
huberman lab on all social media
platforms during today's episode and on
many previous episodes of The huberman
Lab podcast we discuss supplements while
supplements aren't necessary for
everybody many people derive tremendous
benefit from them for things like sleep
hormone augmentation and focus if you'd
like to see the supplements discussed on
on various episodes of The huberman Lab
podcast please go to live momentous.com
huberman we partner with momentous
because they are of extremely high
quality they ship internationally and
they formulated supplements in the
precise ways that are discussed as
optimal to take for various outcomes
here on the huberman Lab podcast if you
haven't already subscribe to the
huberman Lab podcast newsletter it is a
monthly newsletter that includes
summaries of podcast episodes as well as
tool kits all of which are completely
zero cost all you have to do is provide
your email to sign up we do not share
your email with anybody you do this by
going to hubermanlab.com go to the menu
and tap down to newsletter provide your
email you'll go to confirmation link
click on that link and you'll receive
our monthly newsletters and you can also
access any of the previous newsletters
that we've released including the
toolkit for sleep for Fitness deliberate
cold exposure and so on by going to
hubermanlab.com going to the menu going
to newsletter and there you'll see those
as immediately downloadable PDFs thank
you for joining me for today's
discussion about caffeine both its
mechanisms and its many powerful uses
and last but certainly not least thank
you for your interest in science
[Music]